Hello everybody, hello, hello, sorry guys, I had to do some
Vexpo stuff that need, I had to make sure to submit some
stuff or like give notes on some, oh, dad, come on, I'm
trying to apologize.
Why is it, why is it every time I stream?
Why?
Every time he always gets me when I'm streaming.
I he ate at like four he doesn't need more that's a morning
dog treats um but no don't he you're just enabling his I
don't what else can I do what else can I do he's one is that
what you want to hear he won he has one And...
Wait, I ordered an Xbox controller?
I forgot about that.
I...
Oh, oops.
I didn't even realize I ordered a new Xbox controller.
I'm looking at my Amazon.
I should...
Yeah, because it has the button...
Because I ordered it.
Because it has the button symbols on it.
Because I keep forgetting where the buttons are.
I...
um let's see oh let me i i had to order i have to order the
what was what is it called the um the dental treats anyway
guys i had to order it anyway
all right let's see um where is it
I need to know exactly which one I have to order.
It's the dental one.
Why should I buy this again, too?
Let's see.
Where the fuck is?
Oh, there we go.
All right, I need the two pack.
Add to cart, please.
Oh, my God.
$61 Canadian dollar.
Jesus Christ.
I hate this dog's a fancy dog.
To be fair, it's...
It has like...
I'm pretty sure it has more than a hundred.
hundred treats that would last as 90 treats that would last
me for a while that 90 dental dental greenies i got the
greenies um all right proceed to check out all right
continue to check out um yeah i had to uh do give notes
regarding uh the opening concert for vexpo uh embarrass your
manager master thank you for the super chat thank you thank
like stressing both me and my manager out because my manager
is like, I have to be there in person, Doki.
You better not embarrass me there.
I have to look at them in the eyes.
It's just like, you got to be on top of this.
I have to look at these people in the eyes, Doki.
If you fuck up, I have to see them in person.
So I couldn't, I had to sacrifice the leaderboard to make
sure I submitted my notes in time so I could get the opening
concert stuff done in time.
Yeah, he doesn't want to go through the humiliation ritual.
He has to, he has to shake hands and look them eye to eye.
He doesn't want to be like, I'm sorry for Jokey Bird.
He doesn't, I can hide behind him.
Hanya usually.
Papa, it's ridiculous to reach out to you.
Thank you.
He doesn't want to be like, I'm sorry for my time.
He wants to be like, he wants to make sure everything goes
smoothly.
And according to that's it.
I'm giving him a little.
I need to give him a little bit of his food.
I don't care anymore.
He's trained me.
I, fuck, I don't know.
All right.
I'm back.
Oh.
But yeah, that's why I have to be He's like, fuck your
leaderboards, you gotta be on top I was like, yeah, bye bye,
bye, bye, bye leaderboards, I got to look at them in the
eyes, Doki
I have to see them every day at Vexmo, Doki I
Anyway, let me pay for the dog treats Doxins are smart and
birds, a science fact.
Griffin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, anyway, what else?
What else?
Oh, deadlock update.
Um, you know how I won that one game in rank?
Uh, oh yeah.
So I proposed that this stream should I should have one
stream I can veto for data collection.
I dominate this stream it vetoed from data collection the
stream should not count i get one veto one out of 10 streams
and i vetoed this stream if you the thing is the guy said
precedence already by vetoing by not um by not including the
infamous dad poop stream so that means i get to have one
veto for any 10 streams and i choose this one i
I choose this one
Anyway, what was I going to say?
Okay, yeah, so you know how one game The War Dog stream
counts Okay, okay I started a stream on time Technically
Technically I started a stream on time Because I gave 24
hour notice That the stream will be starting later so
technically okay it wasn't okay it was almost 24 hours 15
hours is almost 24 hours i rounded up um and it wasn't my
fault that we were in queue the queue was the game i played
a game there i played a video game there it might not
essentially be war dogs but a game was played a game was
played And I started on time.
What was that?
So you guys know how I won that one game in Deadlock in
rank?
That was the only game I won.
Because after that, I proceeded to, after I had, like, food,
I proceeded to solo queue, you know, because, like, in
placements, you have to solo queue.
And I solo queued four more games.
And then I Guys, I need to get a rat rank, guys.
I need to get...
And that proceeded to have four throwers back to...
Back to...
I didn't know that was possible.
But it had to be on my team.
And I had the first game, A Guy Through.
It was like...
The first game, A Guy Through.
The second game, someone DC'd.
In the middle of the game while we were winning.
Someone DC'd.
And for some reason, nobody wanted...
to leave and I was just like well I don't want to be the
first one to leave and I don't know it was just you know it
was just pure and it's like well I'm not gonna be the first
person to leave and so so we wasted 30 minutes of our time
try I felt yeah I was just like I wasted 30 minutes of my
time in a very obviously unwinnable game and and then the
third game some guy was absolutely fucking wasted on my team
and he was like um i wish i wish i streamed this particular
game and he was just like i'm so drunk guys i just came back
from the bar at four in the morning by the way he was on
east coast because i was like it's 1 a.m here and it's like
i'm so
Got this.
And then he fed like three times in the first five minutes.
And then everyone else was like, bro, just leave.
Like, you seem like a cool guy.
Just, I mean, you seem like a good guy.
But come on, just leave the game, bro.
Don't, come on, Matt.
Like, we know you can't, why are you in rank, bro?
Why aren't you in standard?
And we're like, why are you in rank?
Like, like, how the fuck were you even able to click the
rank button?
it's tinier than standard like and then and then and then he
was like no guys i'm gonna keep staying here i'm gonna keep
playing and we were like and then someone was like bro like
it's like god bro you you're you're gonna get banned but
you're gonna be in bed it doesn't matter the band doesn't
even matter for you because you're gonna be in bed anyway
and this is a loot this game is lose a bowl like like you
lose you're we're you're gonna lose anyway so like what's
the point of saying and he's like i'm trying guys i'm i
think i'm doing great look at me i have so many souls i'm
the most fine person here and and then another guy was like
bro i hope you keep yourself safe But he sent the other one.
It's like, I hope you keep yourself safe.
And he's like, and he's like, I hope you die.
I'm like, yeah, my old shit.
And then, and then one of those, like, and he's like, and
then the other guy's like, guys, come on, I'm on an eight
game.
I'm on an eight game win streak.
Guys, we got this.
Come on, get back to Oracle.
And another guy was like, bro, cheat.
man like that's no we have a drunk man on our team this is
piss low like what do you it's like why is it always my team
and no no not the drunk guy we had our carry our carry the
guy that was carrying us was just like guys come on i'm on
an eight game win streak we can do this we can
and then he's like guys everyone calm down like he the guy
the guy that's desperately trying to win the game he's like
him guys everyone calm we can do this guys it's okay yeah
and he's like this is Yoshi punishing for those who don't
know so you know I'm rival says guan guan and then overwatch
used to have jeff and then so in deadlock it's yoshi um
because the guy has a yoshi has his profile picture and he's
like oh yoshi why must you punish me for winning he's like
he's like thank you yoshi
he's like yoshi please why must i be punished for winning
was just begging and and praying to the higher gods for and
he's for something for a miracle to happen and and then
yoshi give us and yoshi take it and then so um so there was
a huge war going on in vc i wish voice recording was uh
recorded because i know chat is recorded and replays but i
also wish vc was also recorded uh and then i was like yeah
oh my god i'm so you're talking about drunk he's like i'm so
i'm so drunk and i'm just like why are we still here and
everyone's like please just leave bro just leave i think
it's crazy that he didn't leave because i'm like you're
drunk you're after this game you're most likely gonna head
to bed like the band will mean nothing to you because the
band is that it's like two hours like the by time you wake
up by by time you wake up the band will be over so i'm like
why are you still here why like yeah he held us all hostage
and and then i've been dick oh sorry oh yeah and then he was
playing mia mia i don't know how don't remember how
pronounced her name Mina she was putting oh yeah he was
playing Mina and then the guy who was laying with him was
like oh we're fucked bro why are you on Mina if you're drunk
like because apparently she's a she's like a high skill
character and our our vindicto was like why are you on Mina
if you're drunk bro like you're drunk bro like um and anyway
that like broke our vindicta and he just started like
running down at mid actual running i i i finally saw it in
person i i saw the meme in i rl i rl he ran it down mid i
saw it happening in real life for the first time in the moba
game oh my god he he I finally witnessed running it down
mid.
And so, yeah, so that was my third game.
That was, that was my third game.
And then on my fourth game, I, we had like a comeback.
We were losing and then we had a comeback where we killed
everybody Where we killed Everyone when they pushed us And
then we almost We almost got to The first phase of the King
or whatever the fuck is called And then we got Because we
had only one shrine left I mean not one shrine We had only
one one bar left for our Our king Whatever the thing is
called The king thing And then then and then we rushed them
the patron yeah we had one bar left from the patron and so
so we all but then they also had one one we got them all the
way to one bar as well so we we rushed it because we had a
major comeback like it was so lovable we were like we didn't
think we were gonna win and then we had a major comeback
where like we were about to win and the fucking fruit fly
the goddamn fruit fly i thought about going back because i
saw the fruit fly I saw fucking graves trying to backdoor
us, but I saw not every, I thought like, it's okay.
Our Apollo's heading back.
Our Apollo got off point.
Our, during the backdoor attempt, our Apollo got off point.
And our Tao, our patron, Bell.
And I debated, I was like, I should go back.
And I was like, no, he's got this.
It's a 1v1 against, you're Apollo.
It's a 1v1 against you.
against the fucking graves like you you should win you don't
need me you don't fucking need me and then in the middle of
it the thing is the worst part the worst part was that I saw
it happening because I I thought about it I hesitated if I
didn't hesitate for five seconds I would have touched the
point and then we could have killed her we could have killed
her We could have killed her.
Because I was like.
Because no one else knows.
But no one knows how to look at the map by the way.
And rat rank.
It's crazy.
I.
Because it was my fault.
It was.
I put too much trust in my teammates.
Because I'm like.
This is a team game.
I play so.
So many.
Team shooters.
Team game shooters.
And I have so many.
much trust i haven't been in pislo in so long i forgot i
guess you don't understand i haven't been in an elo so low
that that like people like i it makes me wonder why why are
you even playing this video game i
I've never been in an ELO solo that makes me question
whether or not these people are real.
I've never been in an ELO.
The last time I've been in such a low ELO, like, not like,
like, oh my god, unconsensually in such a low ELO was when I
first started Overwatch and I'd like, when I first started
playing Overwatch.
all those years ago and i used to be a plat plat shitter i
used i used to be plat chat and i clawed my way up to the
top 500 from plat chat i
i didn't i was like how do you not see the map it's like
yeah and then and then when the graves backdoored us when a
graves backdoored us my team was like oh wow the graves was
there like they were all so surprised and i was like what do
you mean she's been she was slowly heading i saw her slowly
heading down to our fucking base the last two minutes it
wasn't like peekaboo she's suddenly there you can see her
icon slowly just walking down and like how did you not see
it how did you not see it I don't understand I don't
understand rat rake I think the worst part is that the worst
part is that I'm on rem and I can't really do it like I'm
only as good as I like I My pillows can only do so much.
My pillows.
My pillows can only do so much.
And so I'm like.
I'm just like.
It's rough.
It's so rough down there.
It made me really like these people are.
realities like why would you how many hours have you spent
in this eglow and you couldn't climb how have you not how
can you not read the map i've only been playing for two
weeks and i don't
Hurry, get me out.
Get me out of that rake.
Get me out of here.
I can't.
I'm not.
I don't belong.
I actually, I know some people are like, I don't belong
here.
My teammates are holding.
I don't belong here.
I know I legit believe that I don't belong here.
I, I, I, I-I-I believe in myself that I do not belong here.
I-
So, oh, my God.
I'm actually- I had so much joy in stream.
But, guys, it does- Okay, guys.
because I but when you lose four games back to back to back
and I you can't do anything about it and you're held hostage
for 40 plus minutes knowing you can't do anything about it
that's that's the worst part that's like the fact that I had
three throwers in a row of three throwers and on my team
like more than a dc as well and then I stopped actually it
was five it was five I I blocked out the fifth game because
the guy dc'd I I blocked out the last, I forgot about the
fifth, sorry, I had five games thrown because the fifth
game, I'm sorry, I blocked it out because I was having a
breakdown after the fifth game.
I, that rat rank isn't real.
Like the fact that the thing that surprises me the most was
the thing that there is a rank lower than rat there are two
ranks lower than rat rank like from what no i wish i kept
streaming for you guys the fact that there's two ranks that
are lower than rat i was like how can this get worse how how
can these players get worse like
anyway anyway so the fifth game the fifth game we had a guy
dc for like 20 for like 15 minutes of the game and then came
back so we were held hostage it was no coming back after
that so we couldn't We were held hostage yet again.
There was no, he was so under farmed.
There was nothing I could, we could do.
Yeah, at least they came back.
Yes, but if they come back, it's a guaranteed loss.
If they don't come back, you can leave and then not lose
anything.
We can leave and then not lose.
I don't know.
I don't know why the rat ring people they like I just didn't
want to leave first I but I might start leaving first if I
the moment the moment I see you're safe to leave I'm out I
don't care anymore I I don't I don't care any the moment I
see you're safe I'm out I'm fucking out We're not playing
like chicken anymore.
I do not care if he comes back.
I do not fuck.
I'm not being held hostage anymore.
I cannot do this anymore.
Because they're like, maybe they'll come back.
They're never.
I don't care if they come back.
I hope they never come back.
I do not care.
This is a waste of my time.
I...
We're in rat rake.
I do not care about your existence right now We're you're
not real to me none of these people are real to me none
Refuse to believe a real human being is behind this monitor
Playing in this elo I I might have to build gun rem I might
have I can't do this anymore.
I I might have to build gun rim.
At least I, at least something will die.
I need something to die.
They're all fruit flies at this point.
At this point, they're all fruit flies.
Tell me the fruit flies Elo.
I need a no.
They, I believe, I, honestly, I believe the fruit fly is
higher ranked.
I I won't even be surprised if the fruit fly is higher
ranked than whatever the fuck we are in right now.
Neppers, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
I watched the police body count video where crazy driver was
running, but all five passengers wanted out.
This talk of wanting out reminds me of that.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Do you want to win or do you want to have fun?
Build gun rem and complete the ritual.
to rest soon thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you oh my uh i just it just blows my mind that they can't
even look at like the map like that i'm sorry i i'm sorry i
know i'm talking a lot but it just you don't understand the
most simple thing the easiest thing in this game is that
there's a giant ass map on your bottom right screen that
tells you everything you need to know.
And yet, their eyes can't fucking look down.
Like, you can't even look down for, like, it's not even,
like, that.
I, I, see, my issue is items.
I don't know how to counter-buy.
Yet these people would be like, please buy slowing heads.
please this why does like like fucking regurgitating all
this information that's fed into their brains about like
what's good or not because they fucking watch pro players or
read on twitter to like fucking push like guys remember to
always buy all these things but yet they can't even fucking
have the game sense to look at the bottom right side like
this is the this is like it's like you know how like people
who can only study but they can't apply they can't they can
only regurgitate don't know what it actually means because
they're just dude they're just like book smart but not like
smart smart they just like they're just book smart where
they're just like regurgitating all the stuff that they're
taught to but they don't actually understand this is how it
feels like they'll be like you gotta buy this item oh why
are you building it like this mama but they don't I don't
even have the fucking simple game sense to look down.
I just, I, they can't, they don't have like the instinct of
like actually being a gamer.
Like no adaptability.
Like it's just like all your information is on the map.
All your information is on the screen in front of you.
how much counter-bite shit you do or like but like oh you
gotta do this build you gotta follow this build blah blah
blah it's not gonna do shit if you can't fucking aim or use
your eyes it doesn't matter if you're fucking positioning
it's ass if you don't know how to fucking be aggressive and
back out like it no it doesn't fix that shit if you don't
have the fucking instincts or the games that you're stuck in
rat rank like that's why you're stuck in rat rank no item
will save you no item no fucking build if you're just
garbage if you're just if you're just shit like all right
sorry i'm sorry rat rank is i'm sorry rat rank oh my god
oh i'm sorry the rat rink actually fucked me up bro i but my
build is so opi how can i lose
it just none of this can oh my god it doesn't fucking matter
what you build
player if you can't apply the fundamentals and using your
eyes
all right got your s suit thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you i'm just smiling imagine a world where people
look at the mini map or say lash is missing cool world which
we live there thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you rank changed me as a person i i have less faith in
humanity now i solid thank you the super chat thank you
thank you so i need a moba intervention she's getting full
of eight more than usual 100 agree though thank you the
super chat thank you i haven't been this low and in rank in
so long guys you don't understand it's actually been a
decade plus since I've been in such a low rank and seeing
all of this with my eyes and I can't do anything about it
because I play rem I it's just because I play rem and I
there's an extent to how much I can help my team
all I can do is just watch my team burn.
Eiffen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll be on doing better in rank having your PNG in a corner.
Imagine you yelling me for feeding me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Eiffen, thank you, thank you.
Oh,
my God.
Sorry, guys.
I just I had to get that out there.
It was rough.
I was I it was so rough guys last night The five five games
back to back to back because I kept thinking next game would
be next game was never better Next game was I kept thinking
next game will be better.
It'll be okay, and then I A fifth game has been thrown I'm
like
All right, okay, I'm calming down now.
Just don't think anyone in this Elo is real.
Not even, at this point, not even me.
I'm just like, oh, you're a real person.
Like, ah, okay, cool.
All right, other news.
Overwatch news.
Did you guys hear?
They're bringing back hearts.
Did you guys see that?
Heroes of the, okay, there's so many, news because BlizzCon
is going on right now.
Scum, thank you.
Thank you.
Ah, the later memories.
I'm going to climb a GM in Overwatch Day.
Minus 300 points later.
Think of a super chat.
Thank you.
So, um, uh, for those who don't know, uh, BlizzCon is today.
So there's a bunch of new announcements from, oh my god, I
can't believe I've ranted about Dead Love for like 20
months.
I got to float state.
I, like, locked in there.
I didn't realize how much time I, you guys don't understand.
I had so much, I had so much hate in my heart today from
last night.
I had to get it out.
I, like, it was, it was absolutely terrible.
Um, all right.
Anyway, uh, what are they saying?
Okay.
So for those who don't know, there's a lot of announcement
because BlizzCon, you know, is Blizzard's biggest convention
regarding anything Blizzard related, Blizzard related games,
Overwatch, Starcraft, Heroes of Storm.
So I was talking about Heroes of Storm.
So for those who don't know, Heroes of Storm, technically
all support was cut from Heroes of Storm.
Like they were just given the bare minimum of a support at
that time for a year, for like, I don't know, two plus
years.
And for those who don't know, I think it's because MOBAs are
having their comeback again.
And they want to get into like the Japanese market and or
Asia market in general of MOBA.
So because like MOBA is having a huge rise right now in Asia
again.
I mean, in Korea, it's always been.
But like in Japan and China, a lot of people are like
playing lots of different types of MOBAs again.
Especially in Japan.
So like if you guys didn't know, like Overwatch is very
popular in Japan.
And it's very popular in Japan as well, especially in the
esports scenes.
And so I, this is my theory, but I think it's because they
saw how popular MOBAs are becoming again in Japan in
general, or like in just Asia in general, that they're maybe
trying to bring back HOTS because of it.
But Heroes of the Storm, they recently announced two new
characters, which is surprising because like there was no
support for Heroes of the Storm for the longest time, like
nothing.
The only thing they did was just keep the servers alive.
So it was just like the esports scene was dead.
There was no actual funding for Heroes of the Storm.
It was just as no new seasons or anything.
No new battle passes.
No new updates.
It was just what they have was what they have after that.
And then today they announced that they're adding two new
characters, two Heroes of the Storm.
So it's like people are like wondering if...
it's coming back because why the fuck that's out of nowhere
heroes of storm suddenly have new characters now and it's
just out of nowhere because nobody expected that at all um
so there's that now there's starcraft news they're bringing
back starcraft but all we know right now it's not going to
come out in four years but all we know about starcraft is
that it's going to be an open that's it that's all we know
we don't know what they're doing with starcraft is gonna be
an open world shooter that's all we know they gave us like a
cinematic uh a cinematic trailer but it doesn't really
explain anything yeah it's coming in 2030 so it could be
anything it could be hell divers it could be an extraction
it could be extraction it could we just we know it's open
shooter so yeah but thing is the thing is sex is they're
playing us it could be space marines um because you're
playing you're playing the marines uh god please no it could
be pvpve it could be we don't know we just know it's open
world shooter and you're gonna be playing the marines i will
say though um i wish i could play as a zerg i i if it was
like oh my god if it was like for dead but the multiplayer
left for dead where you can play as the zombies but instead
of playing as zombies you can play as a zerg i would that
would be i would freaking freak out because i think that
would be a cool concept um uh yeah like yeah yeah you can
play as the terran's um i i just hate playing the humans i
hated playing as the humans in general in the in rts
starcraft um but it would have been so fun if I could play
as the Protoss or Zerg.
I don't care.
Actually, fuck probably.
I don't care about the Protoss.
Honestly, my, actually, I give even less shit about the
Terrans.
I just think the human race was so boring to play as.
I think, um, I, I love, I love playing as the Zerg.
Zerg, Protoss, and Terrans.
Um, I don't care.
I legitimately do not care about okay like i told you guys
it's zerg and there's like a little power gap between like
there's a bit like a sort of big power gap between zerg and
protos and then like terran's not even on the board it's not
it's not even on the board when i did like the story
campaigns or starcraft i fucking hated playing the human
storyline they're not as fun honestly uh patrice thank you
super chat thank you thank you yeah but donkey they pulled a
lever to juice that guy's remains out of the armor that one
zerg trade you gotta buy it now patrice thank you with super
chat thank you thank you but anyway that's all we know about
it they just announced open world uh shooter um now the
third announcement for overwatch there was a lot of juicy
announcements for Overwatch.
For those who don't know, Nephru, sing the Super Chat.
Thank you.
But the cool terror music.
But it doesn't matter.
They're boring to play as.
I think the storyline and the characters are much more
interesting in the Zerg.
Protoss is just racism.
Protoss is just the story about racism.
I think the Zerg storyline was a lot more... I think the
Zerg storyline was a lot more interesting, in my opinion.
and Terran's storyline was like some guy that's just trying
to find his hot zerg girlfriend and even then the only story
even then the story the only reason why the human story was
even a tiny bit interesting was because of his freaky sexy
hot zerg girlfriend and she was hard carrying the story yeah
and she was hard carrying the story because she was a super
sexy, hot, freaky Zerg lady.
Yeah.
That's like his saving grace.
Anyway, where was I?
Okay, Overwatch.
Overwatch, there was a lot of interesting updates.
Overwatch, for those who don't know, Sombra has got her
fifth rework, and she is now a support.
Which, okay, the craziest thing about it is that they
removed the hacking ability from Sombra.
So Sombra can't even hack.
It's like, she's a hacker who doesn't even hack.
Like, what's the point?
She can't even hack.
Yeah.
So.
um it's not her old like technically technically her alt is
still the same but everything else is different yeah she she
hacks teammates but like like bullshit that's just a cop out
yeah she's she's tech support now she's not even she's not a
hacker anymore she's literally a tech support so um so they
swapped uh they swapped uh um somber's kit to a support kit
but then the craziest rework that i thought was they gave
roadhog a helix jump so so he can rocket jump that is wild
there's clips i bookmarked it i was like what the bro the
fucking john bro like crazy imagine you're just walking
around a road dog rocket jumps into your face like that's
insane so you can so he now he can he has verticality like
he's a mobile tank now when pigs fly yeah right when pigs
holy fuck Gus thank you the super chat thank you thank you
can you believe you don't prefer protest doorland with all
the doomed yahoo yaddis thank you the super chat thank you
thank you uh just what we needed a flying hog um anyway
there's that and finally the biggest i think the biggest
announcement that i thought was like the most hype for me
also there's world of warcraft but like it provides i'm
sorry for They launched a world of warcraft thing.
I'm sorry.
I don't really care that much.
But, okay, not Blackula.
Oh, yeah, I forgot about the new, okay.
I was thinking about, so they announced a new character and
he's a vampire.
Um, and people are calling him, people are calling him
Blackula because he's a black vampire.
okay but but the create apparently what my friends told me
he's absolutely he's a support character um he's a support
character and he's apparently um uh really really strong
because he like does damage boosts and everything um so uh
yeah it's basically he's basically a vampire support and He
has like mechanical, he has like mechanical bats or
something.
And next thing you know, Randall will lose his shield and
Tracer will become a Tenji.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, he's Dominican.
Oh, that's so cool.
But yeah, that's the new character.
He's apparently very, very strong from what my friends told
me.
We're playtesting him because he's like, apparently the
strongest support right now when he gets released.
Let's see what they said.
They told me he's, he has 11 different things with him.
you have his normal kit and then his empowered kit so it's
like the more you know about him the more you can do and he
does a shit ton of damage and healing so he does everything
so he has two ability two sets of abilities basically so um
i'm i oh my gosh i don't want to learn i don't want to learn
him i yeah uh pat your rest is thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you um i'm gonna be so overwhelmed i
honestly if it's if i have to read an essay uh just figure
out a character like this is why i don't know how to play
support pool like there was just too many things on my
screen if i have to read a thesis to understand how to play
like um i'm no thank you i i have too much stuff to do in
real life like i play video games to escape from reality not
to read a thesis paper and juggle like 200 buttons um
roadhog now has a t3 talent that turns this inhaler into an
aoe so now he is even more like tft too heavy give me the
galaxy cast mr hog thank you the super chat thank you thank
you um what else what else oh yeah anyway the one i'm super
hyped about is that everyone's always said um that they wish
they know more about the lore of overwatch um and then also
to be fair i feel like i feel like overwatch lore has been
like rewritten and what's the word um where they change
stuff after and you're like oops sorry that's not what
actually happened this is what it actually happens what's
the word called um i forgot i forgot there's a word for it
redcon yeah they redcon overlords so much like you don't
even know which like how kierko was supposed to be like um a
baby uh when again g and hanzo were adults and now they're
like oh nope No, Kierkeau was just almost the same age as
them.
And you're like, what?
I thought you, what?
They did not live in the same time.
They did not live in the same generation, bro.
There's so many retcons.
Like, I've lost track on, like, what's true and what's not.
Anyway.
Anyway, so I think the biggest announcement, they reached a
partnership with Netflix series for Overwatch.
So it could go anyway.
It could be cyberpunk or it could be devil may cry.
We don't know yet.
We don't know which, which, which one it'll be on the
spectrum.
We don't.
So we could get devil may cry overwatch or cyberpunk.
punk Overwatch.
We'll see, but we're gonna, I wonder if they're gonna get
the video game voice actors to do the roles or are they
gonna get celebrities?
I'm gonna be really curious.
I mean, I hope it'll be the, I hope it'll be the original
voice actors and actresses.
And also, I wonder if it'd be like 2D or 3D, because that's
what Blizzard, that's what the people loved about
are so good at cinematic trailers or it could be yeah it
could be castlevania i think it's like the spectrum is uh
devil may cry castlevania or cyberpunk because castlevania
season one was good but castlevania season two was was weird
i think that's the i don't know how it's just it was weird
um but yeah i'm i think i'm super excited about the over
also also I want to know if they'll make Kierico the main
character.
They're like, yes, the story about Overwatch.
Anyway, let's follow Kierico's life in Japan.
I need to know.
I need to know if the main character is going to be Kierico.
That's all I need to know.
Toki, no.
It's like she's like the spectator of how Overwatch was
created.
Bro, Tracer hasn't been the mascot of Overwatch since
Kierkegaard's release, guys.
I swear, like, Tracer, like, they do not care about Tracer
anymore.
Uh, all right, anyway, that's all the news updates, guys.
Let's actually go to Onimusha now.
Let's see.
Uh, all right, it's only, it's gaming time, for real.
but all right and that's what happened in the news on the
doki news network come come back next episode for more news
updates where doki updates you on the world news on what she
thinks is important in the world all right it's gaming time
also for those who don't know i talked about this yesterday
but i i knew i knew i wasn't coping but Apparently, in
Onimusha, I'll talk about it again.
In Onimusha, the higher frames you have, the harder it is to
parry or do the easen.
So I knew it wasn't me.
I knew.
I knew it.
I knew it wasn't my fault.
So if you lock your frames to 60 frames, it's easier to
parry.
It's easier to parry.
or do your Easton because the window is like bigger.
Ah, there we go.
Alright.
Yeah, it gets tied to frame rate.
So I need to actually lower it.
I actually have to lower it.
To be fair, I don't think I've been having any issues
anymore.
Ever since I like unlocked the...
Oh, I've already...
Oh.
um that's not
guys guys because i changed it i changed it when i found out
guys i yeah no no no no i changed it when i found out that
see because it has uncapped brain brain do you see that you
see that uncapped frame rate oh wait i sorry i turned it
yeah that was on guys that yeah yeah no guys because i
changed it i changed it before the stream started so i
wanted to show you guys that i that that i already put it at
60 so now the game will be even easier now Guys, I was just
showing you guys that I changed it already.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, yep.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
I was just teaching you guys how to do it, like, where it is
in the settings, guys.
All right, let's do this.
Back to the point with you, the poison swamp.
long you need to stream compared to the other only mooshas
um just because like I said I like I still have some Vexpo
stuff to do um 480 frames of chosen difficulty for doking me
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um we don't
want to oh yeah I want to check the audio real quick alright
okay back to the poison swamp I go
okay Definitely remember the controls, guys.
Good.
Was it A?
Or deflect?
That's it.
Okay, it was A.
Guys, I remember the controls perfectly.
There's nothing here.
Alright.
I just wanted to delay the poison.
Where is the tree?
There's so much malice.
This would be easy.
Okay, alright.
It's fine.
Alright.
Is that the tree?
What is that?
Oh, I got it.
Can you remember the dual wield, too?
Oh my god, where the fuck do I...
Oh my god, a fucking curse.
They are prepared to fight.
Let's do this.
Why?
Oh my god, you bitch!
Give me a sec.
I'm still remember how I'm playing.
Oh my god, you fucking fight me in the malice.
Oh no.
Where do I fucking go?
Okay.
He's not kidding.
No!
Okay, it's fine.
Alright, one down.
Nice.
all right thank god thank god for wall riding
gee thank you for the super chat thank you thank you just so
you know now you have no i don't know what you're talking
about ping there's always ping there i'll always find a way
i'm a streamer don't test me we always find something to
blame nature.
To battle.
There's always something wrong.
Oh my god.
No!
Please!
That's it.
Okay.
Use the pillar's strength.
Oh fuck.
I'm trying to remember how to play, please!
It's been too long!
Okay, there you go.
Are you fucking...
No, no, fuck, I forgot to play this game!
Okay, there you go.
There you go!
No!
Okay, alright, alright.
Alright, it's good.
Not even clear.
Close!
Nothing to worry about!
Alright.
Guys, not even close, guys.
Not even close.
Okay, this is the HP bar.
Can I actually destroy that?
Like, from here?
Okay, yeah, I can.
Guys, three days might as well be 20 years on the internet.
But we got rid of one malice.
Thank the fucking guy.
And Doki time is like 20 years.
Can I shoot him from here?
Where am I?
Where is Doki?
I'll never tell.
What's that?
You'll just fuel for the gauntlets.
All right.
Oh, this is bad.
This is so bad.
Oh, this is so bad.
Okay, wait.
You got this?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, come on, bitch.
Don't give them enough.
happening?
I'm trying.
I swear to God.
There we go.
I understand.
What happened to me?
This game was so easy before.
Guys, I'm just warming up.
I'm just warming up, guys.
Look, see!
See, I got...
There you go, see, see, it's okay!
I figured it out!
It's the friends!
There you go.
See, it's not easy.
It's that easy.
Nothing.
Nothing to worry about.
Oh, shit!
okay there you go see i told you nothing to worry about
nothing to worry about
all right
okay that's bullshit that's bullshit i should have hit that
should have hit i what it's deflect i got the deflect
correctly There we go.
There we go.
I told you.
I got the timing.
I figured out the timing.
I figured it out.
I figured, I remembered.
It's in my head now.
It's in my head.
It's in my head now, guys.
I figured it out.
I figured the timing out.
I had to remember it.
It's now in my head.
It's in my head now.
Watch.
Yes!
Okay, that's bullshit.
That's bullshit.
There you go.
Incoming.
I told you!
I told you it's in my head!
Really?
Is that all you've got?
There you go!
Oh shit.
That's right.
I've downloaded it.
I've unlocked it.
I'm in my flow state.
Nice move.
There you go.
There you go, guys.
We figured it out.
I'm in my flow state.
No,
you don't.
I'm going to get rid of these guys first.
So there's no projectiles on.
me all right come at oh my god you little bitch you little
bitch
there you go i told you i told you i can get my flow state
oh fuck i didn't run oh there you go i told you guys i told
i i just need to unlock the memsul memory I told you I had
to remember the timing
That's one problem solved Well, all right We should move on
now Okay, flow state unlocked It's easy now This is all
child's play
Alright, let's Alright, I'll put the earth shake you just in
case.
The thing is, I don't know where it is, like, there's so
many, it looks like there's so many places to go.
I hope I'm going the right way.
Because there is something below me, too.
Be on your guard.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Alright, watch this.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, you saw that?
You all doubted me.
You were like, oh, Doki's coping.
Oh, she's coping.
Oh, look who's coping now.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Uh.
I'm gonna go this way.
Where am I supposed to go?
I just...
I just happened to forget.
I just happened to forgot the timing.
It's been a while, guys.
I play a lot of other games, so all the other games had
different timing, you know?
I gotta remember which timing is for which game.
It's like a catalog in my head.
Okay, this is the one win.
I wonder... What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Alright, we gotta get that out of him.
There you go.
Nice.
I'll make sure I get the souls correctly, too.
And there's so many...
Guys, there's so many games.
I have to find it in my...
In my...
In my headspace, you know?
The right catalog for it.
Okay, which... My god, there's so many... I feel like
there's so many secret tunnels.
Uh, countering while wall riding.
Press LB and block while you even counter blows by blocking
right before... Okay.
Whoops.
It's okay, it's fine.
All right, this way.
Where is this?
Where am I?
Like, where am I going?
Where is this?
Oh, yeah.
I'm going to go.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'm going to go back because there was more stuff in the
house.
Yeah, I'm regaining the muscle memory, guys.
It's like a file cabinet.
I was, like, looking, browsing through all the files.
I mean, like, Onimusha.
And then feeding it into, like, feeding it into the
computer.
Let's try to find a USB stick.
It's just sticking the thumb drive.
I knew I've never stuffed here.
I forgot yet.
Alright.
There we go.
Yeah, I don't have a lot of hard drive space, guys.
I didn't get an SSD.
SSD, guys.
So every time I need to, like, remember something, I put it
on the USB, or it's a file cabinet, and I add it back in.
What the fuck?
All right.
It's inconvenient.
There's only so little things I can put in my hard drive.
Oh, my God.
This is, like, a little maze, too.
Oh there's one of the trees.
I'll go here soon.
Yeah this is just loot.
Oh I'm so confused here.
You bitch!
She on your guard.
Yeah.
Get up the ladder!
It's the only way.
Oh shit!
Yes you got up!
I actually got him.
All right, because I'm...
Oh my god, no.
My ladder's track!
Oh shit.
There we go.
Well done.
Okay, it's fine.
What?
know.
I gotta use this for heals.
Nice!
Oh my god, the ladder strap!
I don't even need to use the ladder strap.
There you go.
I just do that.
Is that it?
Oh, nice.
All right, stop.
the corruption that was blocking our path has cleared that's
crap there's a tree now there's nothing between us and that
giant plant all
right did
i go down here yet i don't remember oh my god i'm so lost
this is actually a maze like a maze for me right now where
did i come okay this is where i came from because it locked
me in here
Assume this way.
And then...
Here, right?
Here.
No, it was back here.
Alright, it was back here.
And then there's a chest here.
Yay!
They're clearly offering this for me.
And now we're here.
Oh.
Oh shit, where is here?
Wait, where is here?
There's like stuff down here that I didn't do.
I hope that... I hope I don't have to do that.
I hope that wasn't important.
Nightline blades.
Yeah.
Yeah, it sounds cool.
as hell a lot of loot here but no enemy very suspicious i'm
like it's too quiet oh no this is that's an open field i
sense extraordinary i sense the fucking boss fight
oh god oh oh now you can fly
then you'll be able to press the attack okay all right oh
fucks there all right all right all right that's fine no
escape watch closely oh shit oh shit he's Powering up.
I fucking knew it.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
How's this?
Alright.
Good guy.
Oh, I broke!
I got broke.
I didn't see it.
My stamina!
there you go all right no escape all right there
oh my god that's not a good one all right i'm just gonna
keep nice No!
Can you keep up?
No, fuck, okay.
Here we go.
Nope.
Alright, got another one.
Beware his name.
Oh no, shit!
And that's what big mosquito...
Alright.
Oh, fuck, okay.
I can't, I don't think I can do another block.
Nevermind!
I guess I can!
Oh, I guess I cannot.
Are you kidding me?
I timed that perfectly!
Clearly not, Doki.
If you timed it perfectly, she wouldn't be able to hit you.
All right, there you go.
There you go.
You can't win.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I expected more.
Okay.
Oh no.
Oh my god, this is so hard.
This is crazy.
There you go.
Ah, fuck the last one.
Get into the blazing state.
Oh!
Please not, please not second phase.
Oh, thank god, no second phase.
I told you.
I told you I unlocked it.
I locked the fucking third eye.
I figured it out first try first fucking try easiest game of
my life you said I was coping I guess I was coping now I
want me out a game I never copes everything when you say is
facts that was a damn pain that's where I'm locked in now
told you wasn't cope oh great and we cleared up another town
everybody's safe to go out now don't worry about the
monsters three steps been three steps down the block don't
worry about them that took a lot longer than I thought it
Let's get to Gojo or Hashi Bridge.
Benke will be a formidable opponent.
Prepare more.
Oh, shit.
It's Benke soon.
I'd be surprised if there's anything left of that bridge by
now.
The malice has decreased.
And a new path to mastery of the power of the Oni has opened
to you.
Has?
Wait, why is it telling me to go...
Okay.
Oh, shit.
This map is fucking huge.
Just noticed that.
I'm so lost.
I'm so fucking lost, guys.
I know there's, like, stuff I haven't got.
14.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ooh, tune in to the end of the boss fight.
Nice, Stokey.
Thank you.
I know.
That's so easy, guys.
I can do this.
My eyes closed.
Give me a real challenge.
Oh, my.
Yeah, let's give this for babies.
Drake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Did I come from here?
I came from here.
Yeah, I came from here.
Alright, we go this way.
I don't need more water soon.
Yeah.
I might as well...
I should have just turned my modder off.
Maybe then the boss would have an actual fighting chance.
Huh.
This is the way, but...
Is there anything?
Did I come...
Did I go here yet?
Oh!
Wait, this is the path.
Okay, I know I didn't go down.
down there?
Because I didn't know which way was the right way, so I'm
going to go down here.
Grab some stuff.
Oh, I can grab some berries, too.
Might as well.
Did I go here yet?
No, because there's items here.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
This is the area I didn't go to.
Anything else that I missed here?
Because there was monsters here.
Oh.
Should be good, then.
I didn't grab everything.
Alright, time to leave.
Time to leave.
Poop-poop.
Alright, a poison swamp was not that bad.
It was less poison than I thought it'd be.
Thank fucking God.
It really just did not.
I just... I don't know.
I don't fuck with poison swamps.
I think this is the most terrible game mechanic ever
invented.
Where am I supposed to go?
Wait, there was another treasure?
They're not?
I opened this.
Oh my god, there was another trailer?
A treasure?
I thought I'd open it.
Surprise, Doki.
There was one more.
Yeah.
Where is it?
It keeps telling me to go backwards for this.
All right.
Backtrack time.
My guide.
My little guide doesn't recognize the treasure chest.
Which sucks.
Because I'm lost and I don't know where it is.
How do I get there?
Oh my god, it's right there.
That fucker.
all right go down whoops oh i can like kick people on the
ladder
oh my god i hate backtracking so much
i fucking hate backtracking
why aren't you helping me why can't you help me bet oh my
god it was helping me i just didn't listen I was just not
listening.
It was...
Okay.
I just thought it was wrong.
Alright.
This way.
And classic toky.
It was actually...
trying to tell me where to go but a nice find all right now
we can go back thank you yellow paint I'll never doubt you
again oh almost doubted you the rack rat rank rem damage do
keep spray I I don't know how these players get up every day
boot up deadlock and and boot up deadlock and play in rat
rank every day and stay in rat rank i'm surprised that
you're able to like know how to get out of bed and feed
themselves without without medical assistance i don't know
how these players do it get up every day knowing that you're
rat rank and and still play this game 24 to 7
Don't get her started again.
Okay.
Gotta upgrade these.
Yeah, it's a miracle they can even click on the play button.
I have enough for any of these.
No.
Just double checking.
I'd have only a stone, but I didn't want to upgrade
anything, right?
Yeah, I wanted to save it.
Wait, is this one I'm blocking or...
Oh, what the fuck?
That's crazy, but I don't think I'll ever be able to do it.
But Doki is not... It's placements and I'm on REM!
It's different!
Oh, don't don't get me started.
Don't get me started if you...
We're gonna have another hour of this debate.
Don't get me started.
Let's see, we're supposed to go here.
Oh, it's the best one, is it?
Alright, I want to double check if there's anything I need
to do.
Oh, I think we're good.
Alright, then I'll upgrade it.
I don't think I'll actually be able to do it, but I'll do it
still.
Alright, this way.
Do I
like need... Oh, there is new items.
Because I'm like, well, there should be new items since
there's new places unlocked now.
Like chest.
More berries.
More free stuff.
Oh, wait.
There's more free stuff over here.
Oh.
They should Prove no much for you.
Right on target.
Holy shit, why is he so fast?
What?
Like, why aren't you taking damage, bro?
Wait.
I mean, I'll get rid of this guy, please.
Alright, nice.
Prove of strength.
beat you up yeah i know i was like he tanks those
okay more items more berries oh there's a lot of stuff here
i guess because it's a new location more upgrades yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
thank god for all these dead bodies is this new Oh, there
isn't.
I think that has to be...
Here, there has to be a mission here.
I bet you.
I bet you there's, like, a mission right here.
Like, why is there a random fucking pathway to nothing?
Oh, there's a dog here, might as well.
It's in the path.
Alright, hello there.
Oh, it's time to clean the wall.
Oh, oh, he's like a little dog, man.
That's cute.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh, and he took me to the chest!
Yeah, I'm pretty sure it's important later.
Find his keepers.
Oh, he's just like me, for real, for real.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Spread the needle.
Yo, Rava's skilled with that.
Alright.
I love dual wielding.
What else is over there?
Oh, there's more.
Hey, what's up here?
There's so much stuff to explore.
Everything I knew it.
It's always loot.
There's always loot.
Oh, there's so much loot.
I love loot.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
I love hoarding all these items for Onimusha 8.
Oh, I hear a dog.
I wish there's a collapse.
That would be so cool if there was collapse there.
Oh, get inside.
Oh, there he is.
All right, get over here.
Get over here, little guys.
Time to clean you up.
Oh, he's golden.
He looks like a little...
He looks like a little Rotwell there.
Or the ears.
Cute.
I love these little guys.
But not enough to find all of them.
I love them just enough if that they're in my path.
I will rescue them.
I wonder if I can headshot this.
God damn it!
Oh, that's bullshit.
Am I using I got to peek your head.
Come on, you got to peek your head, bro.
Come on.
That's 3D shitty!
Oh my, that's it.
That's it.
I'm fucking... I'm mad now.
Alright, do it.
Do it.
Alright, come on.
Do it again.
Come on.
That's right.
Yeah, not so tough now!
One strike.
That's fucking right.
Not so fucking tough now, are you?
You're nothing.
Yeah, you matter.
You don't matter to me.
You aim and shoot.
Shoot, what?
What the fuck?
Holy shit, where did these guys come from?
I did not notice these guys at all.
Actually, where did they come from?
Alright, goodbye.
Fucking aim and shoot.
Meeting here?
There's so many places to explore.
Oh,
I hear the sound of gurgling right now.
It's over here.
Oh!
You just fuel for the gauntlets.
Can they get closer, maybe?
All right, there we go.
Oh, that's not good for me.
That's not good for me.
God, shit, you fucker!
You little bitch!
Oh, you little bitch.
I'm going to get over here.
Get over here.
I don't care.
Alright.
Oh, there was a fucking...
Oh my god, and I crawled back.
I crawled back.
I fucking crawled back.
Alright.
That was it?
Don't...
Oh, wait.
There's...
chest.
And two leathers.
I mean, that's pouch upgrades.
Fair enough.
Oh my god, I just hear the gurgling sound.
Where the fuck is the gurglers?
Oh my god, I just keep hearing rum rum rum rum yum yum.
He's so hungry.
Wait.
Okay, that's awkward.
Oh my god, that doesn't hit.
That should hit.
Okay, I mean, I'll take those.
Oh, there you are.
There you are.
Are you a little groogler?
There you go.
Let's just see there.
I know they're hiding.
Why are they so scared?
Like a hundred shields.
It's all loot.
Anything up here?
There should be more loot here.
Oh, there I see more.
Are you kidding me?
Okay, I guess it's like a vantage point.
Probably didn't get past that door.
There's nothing.
Nothing at all.
There's nothing at all.
I'll waste my time.
Grab that.
Oh, you bitch!
Ooh, dokey.
Maybe it's not nothing at all.
You fucker.
Oh, these little...
This is you little...
Oh, this is why no one loves you.
It's like up here.
Oh my god, that's why it was a fucking crawl of space.
Well, I fucking did it early, at least.
Alright, now it's... now it's open.
Stupid hidden demons.
No wonder you went to hell.
But I didn't open this.
More cloth.
I mean, more cloth means more upgrades.
Which is always good.
Oh, okay.
Oh, fuck.
He just threw a rock at me.
Why did I shoot his toes?
Okay.
Alright.
Stone.
I'll get him now.
My sword.
Stone will do so much.
That's right.
Oh shit.
His one weakness.
Rock!
Where?
Where did I fucking bitch game from?
Never had a chance.
Bye.
Oh, there you are.
There you are.
That's right.
Now you can't see what you're going to do now.
But you're on.
Alright.
The best, best for last.
Oh, fuck.
All right, nice.
Was that all you've got?
Yeah, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
Okay, this is not fair.
I literally had you had fucking suppressing fire.
That's it.
Where are you?
Get out of here.
You live?
not worth what i know you're put on a good show all right
easy
oh man if only i if only this was closer to me if only this
well yeah they spawn it right here that's it oh okay
crawling here let's say there's no way it's just like a dead
end Oh, there we go.
Boop.
What did it have?
Oh, we have found new pouch crafting materials.
Best we deliver them to a queen.
All right, what is that?
Oh, it's a die.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, there's a fucking shrine.
Oh, we'll go to a shrine first.
It'll be more convenient later.
Thank God you're here.
here thank god if you weren't in my path we'll never save
you and you'll you'll roll here for the rest of your life
he's so lucky spawn in front of my my pathway i would have
never came back for him there we go do this area
there's items here
i wish the scheme has collapsed oh my god that has shots.
Imagine if I collected all those headshots.
It would have looked so cool.
Right this way.
Oh, item.
What?
No, you can't do this to me.
You can't just leave him right here.
Pat.
Oh my god.
You can't do this to me.
You can't.
Just leave him right here so far yet so close that's fucked
that's actually fucked up that's so fucked up oh dokey but
they can and they will she might the i'll do the i'll do it
later i'm not doing it actually it's too far i thought it'd
be closer wait what How do I do this?
No!
Oh.
Wait, but there's a door here.
There's not a door here.
How do I do this?
I can ignore him, guys.
I can do it.
I have willpower.
I'm strong enough.
I am strong enough.
He does not control me.
I control it.
I am the owner.
He has no power.
me I I am the owner are you he has no control over me I make
my own path I am the boss all
right okay There you go.
I told you.
He has no power over me.
I've reclaimed my power.
There's people here now.
That's fucking stupid.
That they're here.
Bro, there's literally demons in the house next to...
Wait, there were...
There's literally demons in the house.
Why would you live next to the demon house?
Why?
Why would these civilians live next to a demon house?
It's this way.
The rent is cheaper, Duke.
I thought, Doki, we've established this.
The rent was just cheaper.
Grab that.
Oh my god, it's literally right there.
There's literally survival of the fittest at this point.
It's natural selection.
Just let them die.
Dad having biblical levels agreed when it comes to food.
Lord Kurosos, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
He's very food motivated.
I swear to God, I think he would, like, will only get
himself kidnapped if it meant he can have more food.
Would I not grab the right treasure chest?
Oh my god, it's over there.
There's another treasure chest that I didn't see.
Alright.
Be on your guard.
Yeah.
How did they know?
I broke one helmet.
Okay, that is not the best.
Alright, let's back.
It's five.
Oh, my God.
What I'm talking about?
Please.
You're nothing.
Oh, my God.
Targeted the wrong guy.
Okay, he'll burn to death, so that's five.
I'll just wait for him to burn to death.
All right.
It's almost there.
See, everything was five.
I told you guys.
It was fine.
Nothing to worry about.
Just this area.
I...
You know, I had a feeling something like that was gonna
happen, but I didn't realize by touching it one time he
would fucking explode.
Just a little...
That's kind of hard.
I don't know.
I thought we had more time.
I didn't realize it was that sensitive.
Okay, we got the shortcut now.
Oh, my God.
Is there anything else here?
Okay, there's nothing here.
Just a house full of explosions.
All right, if this place wasn't overrun by demons, I would
have been a little concerned.
certain about that about that guy i would have we might he
might be on the list not that list but the other list like
an actual watch list you came back no no go had
to clarify of which because there's so many lists you know
so yeah i gotta clarify which one is for which
Oh my god, you're dancing, you're hanging out, like I love
you guys!
Guys, you're my best friends!
I can't wait to grow old with all of you!
Victory's us!
Alright, nice, we got some more stuff.
So much loot to collect.
Holy shit.
I think that's everything.
Alright, let us go.
Whoops.
Alright, let's go back now.
Huh?
Wait, there was another chest I missed?
Oh, it's right there.
How the fuck do I get that?
Yeah, just hanging out.
I don't really want to.
Oh, you guys are idiots.
Don't worry.
I'll protect us from...
Like, this is our one fucking security guard.
Yeah, who will win?
I wonder who will fucking win.
See, I'm going to lure him over.
This is your last one.
All right, you got this, bro.
Oh, he doesn't care.
He's like, I heard that part is filled with...
I heard humans hang out there.
Bro, that's the humans.
That's where the humans hang out, bro.
I heard they're like...
I heard they're like extra freaky.
Where they're in some freaky shit.
Oh shit!
Alright.
Alright, it's fine.
I kill him anyway.
Get some extra loot there.
Oh yeah, yeah, you like that show?
It's just there to watch.
And this is where the loot is.
Alright, there you go.
It's very worth it.
God damn, it was a fucking orange.
What do I do with oranges?
Anyway.
Uh, oh!
I get enhanced charms.
Alright, that's actually good.
That's a good item.
I actually need an enhancer.
I forgot to enhance any.
I only have one charm, though, right?
I'm not enhanced anything.
I'm literally doing default build.
I have to go all the way back.
Alright, let's...
Actually, let's go back.
I want to enhance the oranges.
And I also have, like, stuff to do with...
Yeah, I only got one charm.
I don't know how to get the other charms.
That's why I've never done anything with it.
Oh, never mind.
Guys, I only have one charm.
Alright.
Attack power when suffering.
Blaze.
Gauze.
Increase rate.
I feel like the health would be the best, right?
Which would be better?
Was Blaze, guys?
Or Blaze, Gage?
Or, guys, Blaze Gage?
Or, wait.
Or healing effectiveness.
Healing, right?
Or Blaze?
What do you guys think?
I'm doing Chatbill.
It's good for Perry?
Blaze is my go-to.
I might as well.
I have a lot.
I can keep enhancing it.
I saved a lot of people.
It's fully...
Alright.
It's fully upgraded now.
And now I need to put that on.
Okay.
Alright, we got that.
Also should go.
back there's some tutorial stuff here and some training
stuff to do
all right what do i have to do did everything oh i guess
it's the boss rematches yeah no i'm good it's fine i'm good
nope it's okay i don't need new clothes i'll just keep doing
laundry of my three shirts
all right oh they upgrade my poaches me from using it will
feel the only power and reflex gauges by a fixed amount my
latest masterpiece okay cotton cloth for upgrade i feel like
heels is always better i'm just gonna focus on heels all
right fast travel time
wait does he have new stuff for me.
I haven't talked to the shrine guy in a while.
Hello.
Oh, he just has new stuff.
Ember increases effective enemy souls.
Oh, I actually need cotton cloth.
I have so much money.
As you wish.
Oh my god.
Wait, he's actually...
He has some good shit.
does she even have blaze state I think I don't I don't know
guys everything's a blur sometimes my story goes blue oh my
god need a three wait let me save this dog real quick
there's a random guys guys guys why couldn't you guys
fucking save this dog that's fucked up they just sat there
and watch this dog.
Oh, oh, it looks like a sheave.
It's like sheave colors.
It looks like a dad color.
Something up?
Alright, let's see.
We'll go back to the other guy.
Wait, is that where it is?
Yeah.
We'll go back here.
Because I need to buy two more just to get the pouch
upgrade.
But that's up he's crying you're laughing it is good to see
you okay we need it which one oh we need cotton cloth grab
two more well the city is in your hands all right nice all
right now no don't don't enhance your other stuff dokey
don't do it don't do it you need healing see all right i
feel like i I don't need that many of us, but just in case,
you know?
Old John.
All right, I should give him the rest of his meal.
I realize it's like seven.
I'll be back, guys.
Also, I need to get water anyway.
I'll be back.
All right, I'm back.
Nobody's bite, Anya, Papa, many, four, solid, Alan.
Think of the super chat.
Think of thank you.
All right, let's go.
All right, now we can progress.
Oh, my gosh, this is a TPR.
I was like, where is it?
Where's fast travel?
I stand next to it.
Alright, we go here.
This area?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, wait, ONI portal.
Wait, there's an ONI portal here.
Okay, wait.
Side quest?
Oh, wait, that's new.
Yeah, this is new.
I can give you a second.
I'm doing a million other side quests right now.
Holy shit, that was a bad guy.
Alright, nice.
You're like, where's our hero?
Where did our hero go?
That's how it's done.
A masterful display.
There's loot here.
Don't worry, don't worry, I'll save you guys.
Don't worry, don't worry, I know there's like very important
mission.
Main quest line.
collect all these berries.
Alright.
Oh, oh there's items here too.
Soul Squeezer.
What?
Are you fucking kidding me?
But that's my side quest.
What?
What do you mean?
What do you mean I can't take this away from me I'm side
questing oh wait wait unless unless there's another way I
knew it I knew it you can't take this away from me there was
another way all
right There we go.
You can't stop me from side pressing!
There's a chest in there.
Let's see.
Is that way?
Oh, I knew it.
I knew there was an item here.
I sent some of my people's power hidden nearby.
Why not try searching the area?
Oh, it's Oni.
Since it's the Oni portal.
Is that everything?
Just one guy?
I knew there was never one guy.
Oh my god, we're...
Like, who's this one guy?
Who is this one guy up there?
Who is...
Use the pillar's strength.
Are you kidding me?
What?
Oh my god.
I get out of here.
And then he fucking locks.
Oh wait, it's because he's dead.
Okay, never mind.
I was like, why did he...
Oh my god, you stupid bowman.
You're so lucky.
I'm coming after you.
You're next.
But he's blue.
Nope.
I made it easy.
Well, he's no longer blue.
I mean, he's still blue, but
dead my god he's head glitching me i know it's
over here okay i just want to know if there's anything over
there yeah i assume i think of this way what is that oh what
is that they should prove no much for you all right it's
five oh what the what is that there you
go another strike.
Get out of here.
That's fucking red.
You're nothing.
All those training meant nothing.
See any extra loot back here?
Loot, loot, loot, loot.
This is the right way.
Keep going, Masashi.
All right, this way.
Oh.
Oh, those years of training, you only zero point one percent
of my power the gauntlet is reacting to something maybe only
vision will be useful here time to go into the eye
oh all right what
what i shoot the arrow
I shoot arrow now what?
Oh, there's another way.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Turn like another area I was supposed to shoot, yeah?
Oh, I know.
Me, me understand.
Okay, maybe Meno understand.
Okay, uh...
Surely there's another arrow for me to shoot, right?
I have to go all the way over here.
Me understand.
Oh...
Where are all the other fucking blocks?
Oh my god, there was another way.
I didn't see the other fucking pathway.
Dead.
There we go.
See, I told you.
I told you I figured it out.
Laura tied.
Give me the lore.
I must consume the lore.
There again.
How many gave their lives to cast Yoshitsune into a Vichy?
I shudder to even begin to count.
All of them lost to mine.
failed strategy.
This disgrace is two greats above No, don't kill yourself,
you're so beautiful!
Oh, she's okay.
Okay, I don't think she can live through that.
She had to double confirm.
Because she had like a Oh, shit.
She had extra security.
Body and soul.
I feel not.
Oh, I guess not.
Oh, she's still alive.
And yet, this is nothing compared to that which is like
bears.
Forgive me.
Oh, she's like your mom.
For the pain you went through with Yoshitsune, I beg you,
forgive me.
She looks like her.
None of this was your fault.
I'm just there.
Yeah, he's just like, okay.
Literally third wheeling.
Let us take Stocker to Spirit Mirror.
This is awkward.
I feel like this is a personal thing that I shouldn't be
involved in.
Yeah, that's rough, buddy.
I believe it.
She had two-step verification and still couldn't do it.
It's like when you delete your account and like, are you
sure?
I'll need your password.
I need you to insert your phone number.
I need you to insert the last three digits of your credit
card.
We gotta be sure.
Yeah, I'd be sure if I want to delete your account.
I was like, so you don't want to delete your account, and
then you have to press yes.
It's like, oh, okay, you don't.
I knew it.
All right, that's the second ONI portal.
We're gonna have to go here, and then...
No?
Oh, I have to go this way, anyway.
Okay.
Yeah, it's convenient, though.
Oh, yeah, berries.
I think I don't need more berries.
Oh.
Can I enhance?
Oh, I can enhance all the others.
I have enough now.
Oh, I can lock the third tier.
Nice.
Um, decent power.
increases the number of continues that can be performed okay
we need that actually that's actually good it was this one
draws range attacks and allowing them to deflect it back to
their sources
or do this
blazing skies above one-handed while in oh wait okay we
actually need that okay we need three power stones okay but
shortens okay yeah shortens the charge tab That one's always
good.
I actually want to do this just so that it'd be easier
against mobs.
Absorbs number of souls.
What do we need?
I'm going to grab the charm too.
The charm upgrade next.
Alright, what else do I unlock here?
Okay.
Only vision range is always good.
okay we need power of earth shatter is always good
oh okay we gotta get that one recovery
what's this only strength slice
hold x what oh
my wait that shit oh my god There's more moves.
Okay, apparently.
Okay, the charge attack is good.
Okay, well.
Wait, there's so many...
I missed all these...
Okay, we gotta go back.
I didn't even realize we missed all those chests.
Guys, think about the upgrades, though.
The up...
I think I'm taking...
I'm definitely taking a lot longer to finish this game.
I keep getting distracted.
Good though, guys!
The loot!
Think how big and strong I'm gonna be when I grow up.
All the upgrades and still no pieces.
I'm gonna be so big and strong, you're all gonna regret it.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, they can wait.
What?
All right, now that they're destroyed, oh my god, I can't
wait to get a pair.
Oh, I can't wait.
A pair is calling for me, guys.
You're rather skilled with that.
You have dispatched all off again, ma.
Oh, she's alive.
I wonder if they can actually die.
Can these people actually die?
Master Samurai, you saved me, didn't you?
All right, pair time.
Please give me my pair.
Can they actually die if I don't save them in time?
I just watch.
Yes?
Wait, it's back there?
Oh, shit.
Okay, thank God I actually cared enough.
Right here.
Alright, find Silk Claw.
Alright, now we gotta get the last one.
I'll take that.
Don't worry, the world can wait, guys.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure it's not that important.
The main quest line is not that...
They can wait for me.
Doki, every second you're...
Every second you're not doing a main quest line, they kill
another villager.
I'm like, alright, population control.
It's just natural selection.
At that point.
They're just naturally selected.
what's this way
oh shit I forgot I can't go through the water
what the fuck where are they trying to take me oh up the
ladder fuck I forgot
like millions are getting slaughtered by demons right now
they're like where is the samurai the prophecy oh save us
I'm like, ooh, berries.
Where the hell are these berries?
He's walking over there.
Alright, nice.
Um...
That's just because I'm having...
I have so much equipment on me.
That's why I can't swim.
It's weighing down in the ocean.
Alright, now...
we go here okay now we progress the story oh
that guy spawned back
okay this one i was like where did the thing go well thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you hey dokey my
village was recently overtaken by demons the elder says that
samurai will save us can't wait to be saved why hasn't the
corruption cleared an immensely powerful gamer presence is
sustaining it Benke.
Don't worry, don't worry, I'll be there.
Give me, like, five minutes.
I'll be there in five minutes.
It's just completely destroying our city.
The monster came from over the bridge.
Oh, that must be Benke.
It's been crushing people like bugs.
Why are you still fucking running?
The village is like...
The safe zone is, like, five steps away.
It stopped.
It's like the monsters waiting for something.
something all
right i guess i'll do the main quest line this little that's
just right there is maybe they'll reconstruct a village how
can anyone stand up against that it's just a traffic jam
well sorry there's a huge traffic right now oh my god how
the fuck Do I even...
What?
Whoa!
Okay, this is a little unfair, not gonna lie.
Like, it's like, I should, you should not even be in my
weight bracket.
Like, okay, we are not in the right, we are not in the same
weight bracket, guys.
I felt that one.
He is stronger than anything we're faced.
Yeah, no fucking...
shit we're not going anywhere
if you live by the sword fighting is he's just a tiny bit
bigger than you do yeah yeah he's just like because it's fun
there's like six feet versus five feet plus Dad.
Yeah.
I see it.
One false move.
Well, I see it.
One false move and I'll pull hard.
I hear your strikes from Faden until they come on, my
spirit.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
I wish we could have had a jewel as mortals.
None of these damned powers.
Okay.
Just two men settling who's the strongest.
Alright.
Here we go.
One more.
One more?
There we go.
That should be it, right?
That's one death.
Alright.
All right, there we go.
Two down.
All right.
There we go.
All right, here we go.
One more?
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here!
have a second phase there's no fucking way you don't have a
second fucking phase there's a shred of armor left your
blade should cut deep now
oh fuck let's do this I can tell you have a second phase you
bitch of yours all for show
Oh my god, you fucking need it.
My.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Headshot!
There's my opening.
Yeah.
Oh, you fucker!
Shit!
Oh no.
Okay.
I'm just, I'm going to do that.
Fuck yeah.
There you go.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's take that just in case.
All right
So I'm ready for second phase.
I'm ready seriously you don't have enough I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew it All right Nice, okay, are you fucking
kidding me?
What is the timing for that don't give them an opening?
I'm trying
okay okay there we go holy shit the timer that's crazy all
right headshot how's that huh all
right here we go there we go i got timing
No!
Okay.
Do the head, do the head.
There's my opening.
Come on, come on.
Are you fucking kidding me?
All right.
All right, there we go.
Okay.
All right.
Oh!
And...
Easy!
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
First try.
First fucking try.
Easiest game of my life.
Tokyo.
Got you.
He hit a woman.
This way.
To see Benkei.
That is finest.
And this is what I get.
Forgive me.
Please forgive me.
Holy shit.
They haven't changed at all.
Yostine.
Oh no.
It's hashtag he's over party.
I put so much effort into butchering you down in hell.
That's why he's wearing white.
into that gauntlet he has a wife beater on I suppose if you
are any less tenacious equal rights equal less I would never
have married you huh that's your husband there is nothing
more pathetic than a man who can only thrive in chaos bro
you might have bad tasted men bro you
Yeah, he's a bad boy, but bro.
Let's get you out of there and change into something more
comfortable.
Like a Genma, very popular with dancers lately.
I'll make you into a particularly ugly one.
My treat.
Oh shit.
There's...
This is what's left of your kind, Shizuka.
Let's see.
Your corpse is...
What?
Well, it's in there somewhere, I'm sure.
I'm insted up quite well, so...
This is all I could find.
You despicable?
Before long, the living world will be mine as well.
I'll make a mass of corpses like this of every town, village
and city.
Jesus.
Won't that be a sight?
Musashi.
You and that heap of shit Takamura are first.
You'll both be a bloody pulp when I'm done with you.
He's fucking proud.
Hey, you're married to that guy!
All right, we got to talk about your taste in men, bro.
I'll cut you to shreds before you get the chance.
Scumbag.
Guys, I think he might be evil.
Not sure yet, though.
But, like, from all the context-wise we're getting, he may
or may not be evil.
I'm going.
I'll cut that Yossi-Sinna down myself.
Sit down, Takamura.
What are you going to tell the Emperor if you leave this
place on guard?
Girl, you cannot fix him, girl.
He's like, but I can fix him.
It might be a...
He might have committed genocide, but I can fix him.
I helped him become what he is.
Oh, it was you?
He's just misunderstood.
Sashi.
That is fun.
Defeat your Sitsune.
Save this world.
Not you too.
Stop this, Takamura.
Wait, why not him?
Please.
Doesn't he have more experience than me?
He's my sensei.
If I take this gourdnut off, I'll be a bloody mess on the
floor anyway right what we've been saying there's nothing
for it but to keep filling this thing with gemma souls and
then let it heal you and wait for it to come off of its own
accord yeah but we could swap not much of a choice yeah but
we could swap jobs you know it's like i'll beat out fighting
gemma wasn't i'll take over being guardian of the game and
then use to fight you know you fight
Just couldn't say no to Shizuka.
Your little job swap.
If you live by the sword, fighting is everything.
Let's get...
How is he gonna know?
It's for one day.
Because it sounds like fun.
Let's go!
Do what's fun.
Well said.
when I see it.
That's the zeal needed to perfect an art.
My son of a bitch, I'm in.
He's so cool.
Like, how would the emperor know if he's gone, like, if we
swap jobs for one day?
I've got some Genma for you to fight right away.
I mean.
Or rifts.
I feel them too.
Your sooner projecting into our world may have close to this
hmm every time that bastard shows his face we got a new mess
to clean up
i order food i haven't had my first meal yet i actually i
just haven't i woke up really late i wasn't really hungry
but we're gonna order something right now let's see
i need something at four in the morning that's why that's
also why it's not eighths only have four in the morning so
i'm not like so technically this is my second meal even this
form he remains formidable you saw his projected present
intensifies the malice in the area his strength is
horrifying and yet i can do nothing but rely on you to stop
him if only i had the strength to help first try banke is
what like he's hard or something i told i told you I told
you I needed I needed to find the files in my brain for
Onimusha and boot it up into the hard drive I told you I
figured it out.
I know that I'm a gamer
Pure reaction timing I can adapt I won't go easy on you but
I'm sorry It's much more powerful than when he served as an
Oni Musha, that much I can tell, even from here.
But what can the source of his newfound strength can be?
It can't be Oni power.
He no longer wears an Oni gauntlet.
The fact that he's trying to destroy the Oni gate means that
he's not Genma.
Otherwise, he'd be able to access this world through a rift.
I'm sure he'll find out soon enough.
In the meantime, there's no shortage of Genma to slaughter,
Musashi.
So get back to it.
Alright, let's see.
Is there anything back here?
I've never been back here.
I feel like.
Nope, nothing.
Nothing at all.
Yeah.
Can a rat rake do this?
That's fucking right.
That's what I know.
I don't belong in that, Elo.
I...
Let's see.
Shadow Falky.
There's a lot of missions to do.
I'm gonna grab some of these just to uh upgrade my stuff
There's a bunch here
I'll grab this grab some of the other missions
All right, it's this way right?
Yeah
Hello, sir give me your side quest Don't you have a like We
have a world to save give me your side quest.
I need your items I need more loot.
Where did my damn wife go?
What the fuck?
I'm sick.
And the house is a dump.
If that bitch has time to play at the temple all day, she
has time to do something else.
Why did she fucking left you, bro?
You're the loudest sick person I ever met.
Shut up and get some rest.
Holy shit.
Who are you, Samurai?
Get the hell out of my house.
Bro, I hope she leaves you.
She takes everything you own.
Maybe she's poisoning you.
She gets back here.
I'll beat her black and blue.
She better learn this.
Yeah, she can fix him.
What is it, Murasaki?
Whoa.
I can fix him, guys.
He's just misunderstood.
He didn't mean that.
He's just, it's just foreplay.
This is not a problem to solve.
Even if it does leave a bad taste in my mouth.
Jesus Christ.
Masashi, I am terribly worried about this.
Yeah, bro.
I think she's safer.
She's safer now away from him.
Alright, there's another mission here.
Let's take that too.
I have a request.
I saw what you did.
I saw you take down the monster with a bow that seemed to
pierce straight out of thin air.
So what?
You can tell everyone in the city for all I care.
What now?
I'll even tell you how I did it if that's what you want to
know.
to press it okay it does i see you're not mad who hides its
talent i could have sworn with some sort of secret art to be
concealed from the uninitiated i do not wish for it myself i
only wish to call upon your aid i'll have you hunt some
flying fiends at taking the skies around kyomusudera temple
then why didn't you just say that in the first place all
right the quest for more pairs it's true it's true i was the
pair see i fucking knew it i knew there was something over
there Alright.
It's a true story.
I was there.
I was the pair.
That's right.
Alright, this way.
Uh.
He's behind me.
It's behind me.
Nice quest item.
There's a chest here.
Oh, let me just rob them.
their stuff in front of them let's go lend me your help well
well i thought i waited here long enough i eventually ran
into one one and only miyamoto musashi some flying monsters
are menacing the castle and our arrows barely seem to make a
scratch thank you since you dealt with a new way at the
palace i'm hoping you might lend us your strength it is what
it is oh ordinary arrows won't work on these ghouls i'll
handle them tell your men to stand down all right where's
the last guy though oh there he is i'll grab all the
missions help some monsters broke into my workshop i can't
afford to lose my livelihood hey that's a nice sword you've
got there you know how to use it yeah leave it to me just
make sure no one goes anywhere near the place i'll let you
know when i'm done all right there's another one oh wait no
that's part of the All right, this one's the butterfly with
shadows fall.
Oh, wait, never mind.
Oh, I guess we'll do...
These are the side quests.
Okay, it is this way.
All right, we'll do the side quest.
We'll get all the extra items out of the way.
Oh, hey, another item spawn.
Whoops, what the fuck?
all right
nice there you go saw all of it all right where do i go this
way oh what it was right here oh that's easy
god fucking damn it
Okay, where is the...
Oh my god, I didn't even notice that.
There you go.
Oh my god, no, no, no!
There we go.
Get out of here!
Are you serious?
You want eight?
Okay.
Alright.
Last guy.
Yeah, I'm stronger.
Alright.
There we go.
Oh my god, that one guy.
Okay, if you're going to do an ambush, get like, stronger
people.
If you get one shot by my arrow, I...
You're not really a threat at that point.
Oh.
Okay, now...
Alright, never mind.
You're still not threat.
Oh, shit!
Oh, give me a sec.
Oh, fuck, he didn't miss!
Guys, he was right!
Oh, God, he was right.
He was right!
He should not miss!
I don't know what it is about this.
That particular guy, but he always fucks with me the most.
Like, his timing is always so fucking weird.
What?
Oh, my God.
I don't know what it is.
He's, like, my kryptonite.
He's...
Okay.
He's, like, actually, my kryptonite.
I don't know what it is about this one guy.
It's like rock, paper, scissors.
Okay, all right.
I'm literally playing rock, paper, scissors with this one
guy.
There you go.
Okay, we're okay, we're okay.
Oh, no, we are not okay.
Oh, fuck.
What do you mean?
Oh, my.
Oh, I forgot how to fight this guy.
It's been a while.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, my God.
I actually forgot to fight him.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Oh my god, this is bad for me.
All right.
You must kill quickly.
No!
Don't give them an opening.
I'm swearing I'm not trying to.
There you go.
okay all right there you go you don't need that head anyway
i got the headshot get a headshot all right check your face
don't get ahead of you are you serious
Oh, that's a crab!
Oh, my God.
It was so hard to see it.
Okay.
All right, there you go.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I'll break you and join us.
That perry.
We'll show.
nice one more headshot i've got you now you freak okay one
more one more
it's reaping attacks in malice oh now it's malice time
all right there you go oh fuck there oh i got that just Oh,
I dodged it just the time.
There you go.
Oh, I dodged it just the time.
Oh, you fucking...
Oh, my God.
Ah, you fucking him!
Shit!
Oh!
Don't give them an opening.
I swear to them!
I'm not!
I'm fucking kidding me!
I'm fucking choking.
I'm choking right now.
Oh my god, I'm choking so bad.
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
You may not survive this.
Don't give them an opening.
I'm not going to happen.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, that's shocking.
Oh, I was choking so bad there.
These guys are...
I hate fighting them.
They're so fast, too.
I almost choked.
I got... I don't know what was going on.
I don't know.
These are like my kryptonite.
Them too.
I don't know what it is about him.
I just don't know.
I think...
Yeah, the camera angles also is like a bitch, too, to play
against.
I hate the camera angles for that.
It was just too...
It's just, I don't know, I felt like I was suffocating.
He's so fast.
You're kidding me, you made it back alive?
You got rid of all the monsters?
I mean, I knew you'd do it.
And now, I can get back to work.
I'm so very grateful.
Oh, I get it.
So you send people to their desks and step in.
Once again, I've gone and take whatever spoils they leave
behind.
That's too bad.
And I bet you were hoping to pay this nice story for my cold
dead ends.
Too bad I survived.
Now pay up, buddy.
No use denying it.
Alright, you're gonna kill me.
At least make it quick.
That's not it.
I thought we agreed this was a nice sword.
Not bad to use it on the likes of you.
Go on.
Scram.
But not before you pay me.
Alright, nice.
Ooh, I got Power Stone, too.
These are some good ass upgrades.
all right that means i can upgrade my gauntlet i can upgrade
anything here i can i know i wanted to upgrade something in
power stone which one was it oh the number of surrounded
frozen fear will increase will not work on all enemies
reduces detection um what
did i want to get from the power stone uh it was good
oh the charm it was the charm yeah the charm slot we wanted
that and then after that we want
um i would be gonna do this just so it's easier against moms
so i don't want to deal with like moms and stuff okay we
gotta travel all right where are the quests jesus christ all
right Oh, these are all the flying stuff I have to do.
A lot of them, too.
Or I can equip the heel charm.
I shall upgrade my heel charm, then.
I said his wife comes to Kionizudera temple daily.
The people here must know of her.
Well, there's a... I don't think there's people left there.
The people must know of her.
I don't think there's any people here.
Oh, I have a new charm.
Red Soul Absorption.
I feel like heal is better.
Oh, wait.
The people are back.
Wait a minute.
What?
Okay, I literally hear like...
Okay, why are there people here?
First stop.
This is a very dangerous place.
okay this little dangerous oh yes I know the lady you're
talking about her husband's illness is giving her a terrible
time she comes to the temple every day and prays for his
recovery oh such a kind-hearted woman see she can fix him oh
she's a didn't he say yeah why would she pray for his
well-being There's like a dead guy here!
Why are we here?
Why?
Not any kind I know of.
Why are you all still here?
There's literally still dead bodies here.
What?
Oh my god, there's literally duck- This is literally duck
hunt right now.
There's nothing here!
There you go.
Okay, oh, that rent is cheap.
That can never, we can't always make that excuse.
Oh,
yeah, I know a friend.
Who knows?
Because I was talking about how...
Actually, I don't even remember where the conversation
started.
But, like, he was, like, telling me about how he knows a
friend that lives around New York City or I don't even know
of New York City or New York and how he's like apparently
she lives in the most dangerous part of New York like is
actually like ranked in the leaderboards of like of it being
like one of the most dangerous places to live
and let's see it's telling me he was in a discord call with
her and then like you can literally hear shots in the car
and I'm like what the oh you say like yeah she's so like
disillusioned by it like it doesn't even phase her at all
sorry the rankings sorry I'm thinking I'm sorry I didn't
mean the leaderboards I'm sorry I'm thinking I'm thinking
gamer terms now yeah the leaderboards of the most dangerous
place you gotta
climb the rankings right on target all right last one is in
front of me
if I can't raise it higher I have to like actually walk
backwards to go back and tell that guy oh yeah go here My
thing doesn't take me there, though.
That was crazy, though.
Quick question, Mr. Broken Bond.
Think of the Super Chat, they could thank you.
Armacorn, I'm going to give you a wife.
How many do you think you have now?
Not enough.
A wife for each special day.
Okay, nice.
I'm greedy.
I'm
greedy.
I wouldn't be always over there.
Trey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Solid.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Technically, they're indeed leaderboards for the most
dangerous cities for no apparent reason.
I learned mine is in the top 10.
Leave a super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, that was crazy.
Like, because she's like, she's like, she's so unfazed about
it.
About, like, no, it wasn't Harlem or the Bronx.
It was something.
Let me see.
I don't remember.
exactly which city it was uh most i know like if i see it
i'll know most dangerous city to live in america um if i see
the name maybe i'll it'll trigger something uh
Let's see.
Jesus Christ.
Are you guys okay?
Are you guys it's okay over there?
I'm looking.
There's like violence rate, poverty rate, total crime rate.
I'm like, guys, okay?
No.
Okay.
New York.
Let's see.
I think it was...
I think it was Brownsville.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was Brownsville.
I just thought it was crazy that you could hear gunshots
coming from her Discord call.
Yes, I know her.
She's our neighbor.
husband bullies her something awful poor thing you wouldn't
find me praying every day for a brute like that but the red
was cheap made of better stuff than I apparently because I
was like why was she she's like the rich really cheap I was
like okay I mean I'm like I guess like don't say things
that'll get us in trouble I suppose up ahead is where she
prays let's just hope she's there All right, oh wait,
there's a dog here.
Oh, hello.
Cheap rent is cheap rent.
Exactly.
Okay.
This way.
Have, like...
All right.
Okay.
I get a new drip now.
There's the wife here.
Hello.
wife oh how very curious what I can adopt her two things one
is what our devoted wife is praying to the other is the
rapidly increasing cloud of malice that her intense emotions
are augmenting oh we got rid of the malice serious this area
must still be unstable being so recently purified In fact,
are you serious?
Are you serious?
I just purified.
I know what the fuck, girl.
Use your great power and wisdom to help me.
Fuck this up for me.
Bro, I just fixed this place.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I literally just fixed everything.
I literally just gentrified this area.
Well, avoided.
Oh, come on.
Well done.
All right, is anyone scared?
Is anyone scared?
Anyone scared yet?
Use the pillar's strength.
Oh my god.
Oh, you're scared.
Oh, the archer's scared.
Okay, that's actually very convenient.
I like that.
I like the power-up.
there.
Cheez-y.
Alright, nice.
Are you scared?
No, you're not scared.
Yeah, it's very nice, especially if I'm like, wait.
Okay, wait, I can do this, watch this.
Wait, I can do this, watch this.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, watch this.
Wait, wait, wait.
I can use in this.
Okay, that's it.
I can't be bothered.
I was trying to get the ease in.
They should prove no much for you.
Oh, okay.
Maybe I should not fuck the round.
Maybe I should have fucked around.
Oh my god, there's so many things.
There's so many enemies!
You're street...
Okay.
I beat him up.
Is anyone scared?
All right.
Yeah, I'm here.
Is that all you've got?
Whoa.
Jesus Christ, my fucking kryptonite.
My goddamn kryptonite.
You're not getting the best of me.
No!
I'll get you.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
That was actual fear right there from me.
All right, last one.
All right.
Watch this, guys.
What the fuck is the timing?
What the fuck is the timing, dude?
I give up.
I can't get the timing.
I don't know the timing for this.
I swear to God, please don't come up.
Please, okay, thank God.
Okay, I got scared that big boy was coming in.
I wanted to ease it.
I wanted the Eastern of the...
He died Eastern, but I don't know the timing.
Hey, are you all right?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I was so focused on my prayers.
Did something happen?
No, nothing to worry about.
Everything's fine.
You should leave your husband.
Are you really all right?
I can show you...
I heard you've got a better time, girl.
Oh,
was I too close?
Wait, yeah.
Yeah, that's a little sus.
Then there's nothing for it but to see this story to its
end.
Maybe she was praying for her husband's death.
Every day she's like, please die.
die please die like please don't wake up tomorrow maybe
that's why she has malice in her heart all right we're about
to find out
oh yep there we go what did you mean back there that's why
he was like really sick his prayers were answered
A god that purges bad karma And brings good karma However,
some bad karma cannot be purged In those cases Yashajin is
said to curse the karma's source instead I see Oh, so he
cursed the husband I wonder if his devoted wife knew We'll
leave that mystery Tantalizingly unsolved Oh, I see Oh, so
she, yeah, she cursed his husband to die.
I hear she's been getting along well with the vengeful
fellow we met previously at the Stone Lantern.
Oh, shit!
She's a gold digger.
She upgraded.
You did well, Musashi.
Now, remember that other guy?
The guy that was like, got avenged my brother.
or some shit he was rich as hell yeah
she upgraded she moved on quick I'm not gonna lie she
fucking moved on quick that was crazy like my husband said
oh shit you were single too oh hey that was fast I think we
finished all the quests here right i want to be sure there's
no bonus quest oh bonus quest um and where do i which way do
i start i should start i'll start here because i can go down
oh what the fuck okay there is a dog next to me
what's the dog doing
all right
Hello, little guy.
Get purified.
Alright.
How do I get this?
Like, where is that?
Hey, Doki, the demons burned down half my village.
But surely this...
Don't worry, I have five minutes late.
There's heavy, really heavy traffic right now.
They are prepared to fight.
Let's do this.
I'll be there in five minutes.
It's just unfortunate.
Bad traffic.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Damn, don't you just hate?
You just hate that, you know?
Just so unfortunate.
Where is this pig?
Is he stuck behind the wall?
Oh my god, she spawned inside the wall.
How the fuck?
How do I kill her?
Okay, this is bullshit.
Oh, it's a puzzle?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they go up here and shoot below.
It's goddamn pigs.
Get out of here.
Impressive bow technique.
Okay, but how do I get this one?
All right, I'm gonna figure this out, I guess.
I don't realize it was more of these fucking pigs.
Something's off.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, my story is so strong, I don't even need it.
Like I just out-damaged that instantly.
yeah
all right anybody that below me I just want to be sure me
too oh there you go all right that works
how hungry Drake thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you I see you
How can you be stuck in traffic?
You're one of two people that can teleport through mares.
There's a queue.
There's a...
There's a queue right now.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
Gotta go straight, dad.
Where's that coming from?
What?
Oh my god, he's in the archer's nest.
Yeah.
Got watermelon.
I'm glad you run home.
Watermelon.
You're going to have to do better than that.
Alright, there's two over there.
Oh, shit.
No, no, my kryptonite.
It's him.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
Thank God.
Thank God he had...
Thank God I was able to headshot him.
It was.
Savvy, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
We had a good stream.
I hear him.
Where are you, little picky?
I'm going.
Where are you?
Where is...
There's nothing here.
Oh, there she is.
How close that to be?
Okay, there you go.
technique there was down here so soon you need to angle
there or some shit the family will perish the demons while I
watch helplessly do a 659,669 people waiting in the spirit
of Mary yeah guys I'm in queue guys give me a second I gotta
wait in line no it's war dogs all over again okay I know
you're here how the fuck do I angle it sorry my Q reset oh
my guys let us return and tell him all right we did it you
just need better service sorry the the mirror downgrade and
servers they're getting DDoSed it's not It's not my fault.
Maybe you should have told them to invest in better mirror
servers if you want to be saved.
There's a dog in this map?
Yep.
It sure is.
I finished it.
I mean, I do have enough for drip right now, so I might as
well redeem my drip.
Yes, and?
What about it?
Alright, I get my drip.
Musashi, you've done very well helping my lion dogs.
Aw, she doesn't have more dogs?
I thought like the more dogs I get, the more they'll show up
in their room.
They are, they're really cute.
Here, a token of my gratitude.
Please accept it.
all right what kind of trip do i get this time i get oh i
don't know i already like my sword though oh it's just for
swords and i'll change like i guess outfit the regular
outfits would be from the boss rush i guess all right what
does it look like oh shit okay wait a minute i oh wait what
the oh my god bro made out of real time my handle has a face
on it all right let's just redeem this shit damn my blade
fucking has his own first-class seat as his own that's his
own vacation home in LA I'm grateful I heard the good news
you took care of the monsters at the castle We wouldn't
happen to be taking it on pupils, would you?
That's not it.
You can't teach this shit.
Yeah, you gotta have a demon.
You gotta make a deal with a demon.
Lucky for you.
Believe me, stay human.
It's underrated.
I can live forever.
We got power stone.
That means more upgrades.
And now we gotta go redeem this one.
And then we can continue our main quest.
I know.
It's made out of tigers.
It's like I have a tail.
Wait, where's the other guy?
The other quest giver.
Should be here.
Alright, there you are.
Oh, goodness.
You really managed to deal with all those flying monsters?
I must say I'm very impressed.
I couldn't hit myself.
Not even with all the many years of training.
Come on.
You mean you try to fight them and live?
Look.
There are no ordinary monsters.
You're lucky to be alive.
Yeah, well, they almost got me, but I managed to skate with
my life.
And not long after, I saw a shoot one down like it was
nothing.
Which way I knew you were the man for the job.
My thanks.
Thank you, friend.
I'm forever in your debt.
All right, nice.
Yay, more upgrades.
Yippee.
Oni stone.
That's more of a power-up.
upgrades too all
right well i have i can use it here now yeah this is for the
only stone oh yeah this one the one-handed attacks we want
won't try that with
oh i guess it's for like i i feel like i would only use this
for uh the mobs honestly I don't think I can use that for a
boss fight, right?
It's, like, not convenient for boss fights, right, guys?
I don't know.
Yeah, like, the AoE is mostly for, like, little guys.
Yeah, it's just crowd control.
I was thinking that...
I was thinking it was just more for crowd control.
Why are they blue now?
Are they, like, supposed to be stronger?
Oh, yeah, they're definitely supposed to be stronger.
Oh, yeah, 100%.
All right, get out of here.
Still predictable.
The pellet strength could stagger them.
Oh, I forgot.
I thought I'd be stronger.
All right.
Yeah!
There we go.
Thank God I got scared.
Very convenient for me.
Oh, I can't open that door, so I have to go this way.
Oh
my god, I could have used my charge attack.
I already forgot the charge attack.
I already forgot to use it.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, big guy.
Okay, that was close.
Alright.
Get out of here.
I'm here for my pair.
Give me my pair.
wow you're so strong master samurai so strong you saved my
life thank no problem where's my pair all right oh beans oh
they're expanding their pair market now now they handle
beans and pairs where is this area i wonder if it's gonna be
a boss fight or
oh i got it He's like, get down, Mr. President!
There you go.
Is everybody?
That should be everybody.
Oh, never mind.
He wants to join in, too.
Okay.
So what's this?
Rift.
All right, we're grabbing this first.
And then we'll do the rift.
Am I heading the right way?
What?
Oh, God.
What do they do?
What do they do more?
I assume the red spot is the weak point.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, loot.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Look!
Wee!
Look, loot, loot, loot.
Alright, jump.
Alright, where are they?
Oh, it's right there, I see it.
Alright, this is where I use the crowd control.
This is it.
Come on, get over here.
Okay, that's nuts, I don't know.
Okay, alright, well...
Well, now we know!
There's no...
Shoot the rift with your bow.
Oh shit!
Only for a moment.
Its connection with Avicii should weaken.
Alright.
The Rift gives it how long it will be before the Rift begins
producing malice, attacked and destroyed before it can...
Oh, okay.
When fully connected nearby, can we heal or enter?
Alright, I think I...
Oh my god, I was...
Oh my god, suck me off!
That freak!
Alright.
I'm supposed to do the suck suck oh shit what how am I
missing miss us you ship the rift with your bow even it's
only for a moment it's connection with Jesus Christ, you
fucker!
There you go.
And then power.
Alright.
Suck!
You're gonna decide me.
You'll just fuel for the gold.
Oh no.
Okay, I'm gonna have to get rid of this gap first.
Ah!
only for a moment its connection with adventure should
weaken okay this is oh my god please there's so many enemies
no no no no no no no no no oh my god thank god he saved my
life thank god thank goodness he saved my life guys
very nice of it shape the rift with your bow I plan why do
you not see I'm fighting 20 different people right now
please oh god okay got it got it I got it okay this is the
worst mechanic I do not like that mechanic.
I do not like it at all.
I am not a fan.
I am not a fan of this.
This is looking grim.
It's just so, like, there's 20 people shooting and I have to
shoot the Rift 2.
I'm not a fan of this mechanic.
Not gonna lie.
I think this mechanic is at.
The Rift seems unsteady.
Boy, I recognize this presence.
What is it now?
The Rift This connection to Avicii will strengthen you.
The gem on the nearby will only grow stronger at this rate.
Alright, we got this one.
Radios Masashi!
Shoot the rift with your bow!
Oh my god, please!
It's connection with Avicii should weaken you.
Alright.
There we go.
That's fine.
Alright, get over here.
Get your ass over here.
here fucking right you're just an archer to battle
aim for the exposed dogs oh please I don't don't worry I've
tried there you go it's a connection with a bitch you
shouldn't we you fucking you fucking you Bitch!
All right, we got him.
There you go.
All right, it's just 1v1.
Just a 1v1, bitch!
There's a 1v1 now!
Shift the rift with your bow.
Even if only for a moment, it's connection with a bitch you
should.
It's weakened.
There you go.
Oh, fuck it.
No, you don't.
That's right.
I swear to God, there's more.
I swear to God.
AOE does nothing.
It barely does any damage.
I don't know.
I tried it.
It barely did any damage.
To shoot the rip of your boat.
Look.
crazy old blue made by playing a summons flaming what first
rb when oh it's just another move which i guess burning and
staggering them this one parlor trick and look what happens
oh was it armored oh my god but they were all armored
majority of them were armored though
What's...
Is the...
Is the flute bird...
Is the firebird flute even good?
Okay, we need a...
Wait, I need a...
I need a grab, like...
I need to enhance my healing charm.
Here I go here and then...
Yeah?
What's the firebird best for?
Guys.
Okay, nice fast travel.
Is it good for bosses?
Better than the Earthbreaker?
Okay.
Because I'm wondering if it's better than Earthbreaker,
though.
Oh, I'll think about it.
Upgrade these first.
Alright.
Gotta travel.
I'm gonna travel back here so I can upgrade my charms.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I feel like that's best for bosses.
Alright, here's auto.
select on hence hence should be full nice thank God saving
all those villagers amounted to something let's go here oh
my gosh I always the time it's the shooting thing again
though it's the worst I tell me where to go little guy is
this way oh left my path be on your guard yeah shoot him in
the stomach see if it does more I don't know can't tell
because I assume because it's red like it's a tumor I would
do more damage but I can't tell all right
spare time I saved your life now give me a pair I thought it
was all over for me thank you ever so much and no problem
now give me my pair five headshots still better I'll just
use headshots still yeah God that's so satisfying huh is
that That's it.
There were no much for you at all.
What the fuck?
Bro, he's trying to head glitch me.
Whoa!
Okay, I see him.
Let's do this.
There you go.
Dragon.
Alright.
Boom!
Easy.
All right, we reached our destination.
Shoot him in a stupid metal hat.
Why didn't shoot him in the metal hat?
Oh my god, he has so many.
They all have hats on.
It's not fair.
What do you mean they all have hats on?
Oh, wait.
Nice.
You're scared.
Never been this far before.
All right, nice.
Never been this past the border before.
Ooh?
Oh.
Can we even...
Can we get him?
All right, there we go.
You're rather skilled with that.
Wait, there's some chests that I missed.
I see some loot.
Wait, I can't even get it.
How do I get this loot?
Oh my god.
Oh, they're just...
They're just like, what's up with him?
They're like, these humans are weird.
You did well to rescue them, Masashi.
hang there i thought it was all over for me thank you ever
so much you go check this out britney
oh sake i got sake though not worth it i unlocked the
shortcut too shortcut oh more berries
wait more loot
More loot I'll never use!
More loot!
Even more loot I'll never!
Oh wait, actually, I actually would use that one.
Anything up here?
I fucking knew it.
always loot.
Wait, there's stuff here.
Huh?
Oh, I was like, I heard some chirping.
Let's grab this.
And then...
Oh, it led me all the way back here.
It just led me to the other side of the bridge.
Guys, I don't need to use items.
I'm not weak.
Why is there an only power here?
Do you guys see that?
Oh, is it just...
Oh, it was for this mouse so fast.
I ain't no pussy.
Oh, my God.
My God.
There is fall damage?
Since when was there fall damage?
That's fucked.
I've never had fall damage until now.
Anything up here?
Oh no, I was.
I came from here.
We need to use items.
It's a skill issue.
Alright, we're good to go.
Ah, fuck up here, yo.
We have this though, this tab.
Actually, I don't want to use that for these guys.
These guys are like, weak.
He's like, I heard you talking shit.
There you go.
Yeah, don't take it back.
That's right.
But take it back.
No.
You are weak.
That's right.
Oh, that's not what I wanted to use, but I'll do it.
Oh my god!
Just in time!
Wait, that's it?
Holy shit, I did the harder one first.
I did the harder one first.
That was actually it.
Are we done?
And they gave me so many things.
They gave me like 20 fucking environment shit.
return to Rokudo Chinuji immediately.
What now?
A new story.
Alright.
How do I leave?
There's berries though.
Yeah, this one they gave me like 800 environmental kills for
five enemies.
That's bullshit.
Let's go here.
And then...
So we can TP back home.
Alright, tell me how to go home.
Whilst fighting for my life in the other area.
Oh, small fry.
Right on target.
Shit, I'm like...
Alright, let's go.
That was one-sided.
Let's keep moving.
I literally have a gun.
Alright, back to the village I go.
What the fuck are they doing over there?
Back to the village I go.
Oh, wait, I can enhance.
Enhance.
Alright, travel.
Alright, I did my thing.
Oh!
The Yoshisunui when it's at Gojo Bridge was not a physical
entity, but merely a spirit like myself.
Even this form, it remains formidable.
You saw his projected presence intensify the malice in the
area, and yet I can do nothing but rely on you to stop him.
If only I had the strength to help.
You're doing good work, Musashi.
But Yoshitsune's Genmaha, in a word, relentless.
You purified Kaninji Temple once, but they just took it
over.
again ah the big guys come back what big guy what the fuck
is the point of he just come back and that goes double for
key sanctuaries the ony gate must hold without the gate
yostane would be free to enter our world it's bad enough
when you're just showing up as a ghost i'll go and sort out
the big guy ken ninji temple
Alright.
Alright, time for boss fight.
You have reached a deeper understanding of the power of the
Oni.
Oh, it's just another boss rush.
Alright, boss time.
Boss fight.
It has to be a boss fight.
What else could it be?
That's true.
I'm just one guy.
That's actually true.
Oh my god, wait, is it the brother?
It's the brother.
It's the fucking brother.
It's the other brother.
Alright.
Let's fight the other guy.
The other guy didn't kill.
I had a feeling.
I mean, it's like the same area.
It had to be him.
Sounds like we were right.
Oh, wait.
Playing music for me.
Hey, guys.
Having a party without me.
Aww.
Trying to get by.
up for a jewel here
here it comes what
why aren't you afraid oh god this guy out All right, nice.
My kryptonite, my kryptonite, my kryptonite!
Keep your eyes on the wrecked.
No!
My fucking kryptonite!
Okay.
I'm gonna get rid of you.
All right, it's just you and me.
All right, it's just something about you
I don't know why Why are you so hard
Oh my oh my god Okay
It's all right, he's gonna spot another one isn't he he's
gonna fucking spot.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
I'm sure of that.
I'm cool of that.
There's just something about it.
There's something about that one enemy.
I can't, I don't know why I can't.
It's like rock, paper, scissors.
I play rock and he always play paper.
And then I never change my move.
Alright, now I'm ready for the party.
I should have healed.
Okay.
is electricity hey nothing in your eyes today you took real
good care of my little brother oh shit bro this is a fucking
Japanese rave time to return the favor oh we're in the club
right now
honestly is that what oh okay
oh my god what the fuck Jesus Christ okay no mercy all right
this is a little That's hard.
That's fast.
He's blocking all I've got.
All right.
Let's make this flushing.
I want to know the timing for that, though.
Jesus.
Is that all you've got?
Yes.
Headshot!
And I know...
I can already tell he has a second phase.
I mean, his brother had a second phase, so I'm not
surprised, you know?
Take this!
Okay.
Alright.
Thunderbolt!
Okay, no, I didn't get it.
Let's make this flushing!
Fuck!
What the fuck is the timing for that?
All right, there you go.
Okay, I got it.
You won't hit me.
All right, I got that.
I still don't really know it, but I'll take it.
Okay.
It's fine?
God damn it.
There you go.
It chops!
Bring it on!
It's fucking right!
Oh, you bitch.
All right.
Okay.
It's good.
You're doing that?
You're just like us.
There you go.
How did you reach such a fast attack?
What the fuck?
What is that bait?
Oh yeah.
That's fucking...
He fucking baited me with that too.
It's fine though.
There you go.
Nice.
I'm just getting started.
Burn!
Oh, oh.
Georgia died!
Holy shit!
Okay, I didn't want me to do that time if I'll take it.
Get him!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that was...
I got up there.
okay let's make this flushing oh fuck wait oh my god wait
okay wait wait my food my now I'm gonna lose myself juicy in
the elevator use use intercom access
elevator instructions all right there are instructions ah ah
okay they didn't read the instructions they didn't read the
instructions i gave them they're like i'm gonna put it in
the lobby i'm like no
what what i didn't receive call i'm confused thank you
called wrong person they're like i did use the intercom and
i'm like i didn't receive a call what do you mean there's no
way you receive you there's no way
sweet code
all right whatever they're just gonna leave in the lobby
This is sweet code.
Oh my god.
Okay, that was, that's fresh.
You're like, someone picked up the, they're like, yes, you
picked up the call and let me in.
And I was like, what, I, this wasn't me.
Yes.
I was like, that wasn't me then.
This is me that I fucking answer to the call.
Like, I didn't receive any call.
He said someone let, like, someone, you picked up the call.
And I was like, this is not me.
Alright.
You're like, can I put in a lobby?
I was like, I won't be in the lobby for a while.
It's easier for me to go out rather than go down.
Alright, they're gonna do it.
Yeah, I was like, who picked up?
That's why I was like, There's no way!
I did not make...
Oh my god.
This is bad for... This is so bad for me.
Oh, this is not fair.
I'm out of my groove now.
I'm out of my groove.
I'm actually...
Okay, there you go.
Bye.
Okay.
Sorry.
Saw it coming.
Oh, thank God.
No!
Thank God!
Okay.
Oh, I can't do anymore.
No!
god damn it i'm actually out of my i'm out of my room okay
please oh my god oh my god uh sorry okay
oh my god
I'm actually so tilted I'm so tilt he's like it's not my
fault so I'll do what I was like sorry my perception was
poor I'm I'm so tilted this guy is oh my I'm so I'm like I
don't if I lose this because of it I'm so I'm gonna be such
a fast attack I would be so mad if I lose this fight because
of this.
Okay.
Let's make this flushing!
There we go.
Saw it coming.
God damn it.
No!
Okay.
I'm actually... I'm gonna be so mad.
I'm...
If I lose this fight because of him.
All right, nice.
There we go.
You won't hit me.
I got the timing for that now.
Not for that apparently.
You bait a seed.
He always baits me for that.
Okay.
Is that your best?
That's right.
all right all right nice nice no y'all you got you got oh my
god this one oh the win is mine first try First fucking try
to spite everything despite everything against me
I'm a bad dude.
I Killed him before I could say thanks It was oh My god
Forget it.
Let's get out of here.
I feel like his little brother was harder than this I don't
know just because I got better.
I don't know.
I'm one.
Bad guy.
I swear to God.
Oh my.
Oh my God.
I was so not locked in there.
I was not locked in at all.
And I was so frustrated.
You guys are so fucking frustrated.
14, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, nice
fight, dude, you gotta go to bed, it's one hand for me, have
some money for yourself, but thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, I was so mad, I can't believe the only times
I've died was from the fucking mods, these mobs, these
goddamn kryptonite, I don't know what it is about them, I
just can't, they're just so confusing, Oh, Master Samurai,
please help me.
There's a murderer.
You gotta be specific there.
I think everybody, like 90% of people here are murderers.
It's like a pagoda.
Our samurai went to stop him, but none returned.
The villain, he seemed to be out of his mind.
Which one?
Does he have a metal hat?
Yes, yes.
Who the fuck wears a metal hat?
Do you know?
Lucky guess.
i'll deal with him don't let anyone else try yeah i had a
feeling it's gone room yeah it's a guy with a metal hat who
else could it be oh my god it's so far i'm fucking goodbye i
no i'm a colleague i think i think we got here i did say
today was going to be a A little bit shorter stream, even
though it is still four hours.
I'm going to call it here, guys.
Just because I want to eat.
And also have some...
I have some Mexico stuff I need to finish up on.
Did you get me anything?
Did I?
No, I didn't.
But thank you, everybody, for watching.
Yeah, this game is so easy now.
It's literally just the mobs that's fucking with my...
Like, I don't know, the bosses are much more easy to predict
now, now that I like know what I'm reacting to.
Um, I know exactly how to deflect it.
It's just, I don't know.
I just, I get overwhelmed.
If they fucking throw, they throw, like, when they throw
like 20 enemies at me, I just forget everything.
I'm just, I'm like, there's too many, too many things on my
screen.
I don't know what to do.
Uh, but anyway, guys, I hope you guys enjoyed watching.
stream for you guys uh and it's been fun this game has been
really fun um the uh we first tried all the bosses today too
so it's been very enjoyable uh and yeah as always everybody
stay hydrated posture check get up and move around and get
that blood flowing if you except for me head to bed cause
you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys bye